e
e e
the house will come to order the chair
recognizes a member from Auburn
representative orsburn who moves the
house adjourned from the session of
March 6 20125 are you ready for the
question all those in favor say I I
those oppos nay the eyes have it house
is adjourned house will attend to a
Prayer by house chaplain Reverend
Jonathan Hopkins Pastor Cordia Lutheran
Church in
conquer
morning let's
pray dear God we ask that you would
bless our state with your wisdom your
love and your
compassion we ask for blessings on our
leaders May these servants who are in
positions of authority take that
responsibility seriously and do their
very best each day they have a passion
for people for truth and for
righteousness may they always seek not
their own good but the good of the
people that they are elected to serve
may they speak to one another with
courtesy and decorum that befits the
honor of their calling Grant to them at
this time special gifts of wisdom and
understanding of counsel and strength
that uplifting what is right and
following what is true they may fulfill
their spiritual purpose of service to
their F fellow men and women we ask for
blessing on our servicemen and women
this day we ask protection for all our
men and women in uniform both here and
around the world we are grateful for
their service their dedication to
keeping our nation safe we pray that you
would keep them safe and thank you for
blessing us with life and Liberty May a
work here in this chamber show love and
honor to all the citizens of the state
and Country may we reach out to all
other nations and people and groups with
a strong desire for peace and Harmony to
be displayed wherever possible
amen the chair recognizes a member from
londondary Ron dun who will leave us
lead us in the Pledge of
Allegiance the United States of America
to the repic for it stands one nation
under God indivisible liberty and
justice for
all the chair recognizes the rhythm of
New Hampshire Show Chorus will'll Now
sing our national anthem
[Music]
so
we the Twilight
[Music]
flag still
[Applause]
the house will attend to request for Le
of absence Mr Speaker the day illness
Representatives robley Hall papichi
Mueller the day important business
represent resentatives eel Grill
McKenzie Michael Murphy Mark pagee
Jonathan Smith and Summers the day
illness in the family representative
sudor the day death in the family
representative
levit these leads of AP shall be granted
unless otherwise ordered by the house
the house will attend to the
introduction of guests Mr Speaker please
welcome Summer Campbell student from
Sanborn Regional High School and sheay
belli student from Windam High School
our Pages for the
day welcome to Hampshire
[Applause]
house and Mr Speaker please welcome
Charles CIA and Katarina jurus parents
and daughter of Representative jurus
they are with us in the gallery today
[Applause]
also attend to a communication Mr
Speaker in a letter dated March 10th
2025 dear speaker Packard it is with
mixed emotion that I submit to you this
letter formally resigning from the New
Hampshire House of Representatives
effective March 10th it has been a
privilege to serve the people of New
Hampshire and work alongside my
colleagues during the last six terms
promoting the New Hampshire advantage
and making our state the best place
place to live work and raise a family
however I am honored to receive and have
accepted an appointment from president
Trump to serve as FEMA administrator for
region one I look forward to continuing
my commitment to public service in this
new role leading the effort to ensure
the Readiness and response of our
country and specifically our region
thank you for your steadfast leadership
and support sincerely representative
Fred
duet resignation is accepted with regret
the chair recognized representative
parel for Memorial remarks for the
former member from Kane The Honorable
Timothy
Robinson the house will be in
order thank you Mr
Speaker Tim Robertson served 189 on
consecutive terms in the New Hampshire
state house he died peacefully at
covenant living of Kean on January
29th Tim service in the house extends
back to the last Millennium and
concluded in 2016 Al although he did
took a break in 2010 to run for
governor Tim sponsored at least 25 bills
in the house but said he couldn't think
of one that he sponsored that pass for
some odd reason I find it's an
inspiration it was Tim that urged me to
formerly enter
politics I got to know Tim Robertson in
connection with our local Unitarian
Universalist Church where we both served
in multiple positions including board
president I enjoyed many passionate
arguments with him while we're not
always in agreement I always felt
validated and better for our
conversations Tim was also an army
veteran and while I did not serve with
him we were pressed to serve as winkies
for the Wicked Witch of the W West
sharing a stage in the local Lions
production of the wizard of
AZ while attending hobbert and William
Smith college in Geneva New York Tim met
Elise the love of his life and who is
better known as toow she was his wife of
61 years and pred deceased
him Tim returned with talloo to his
native King in 1964 to race her three
children Andrew Christian and Lincoln
Tim was active in state and local
politics where he exhibited genuine
empathy for for all I always found Tim
to be open but also fiercely independent
and always willing to think outside the
box Tim actively supported the work of
the Keen YMCA both financially and
advocacy and was instrumental in moving
them to their new facilities and as I
alluded to earlier he also served as a
longtime member of the Lions Club and
was fundamental in the early support of
our 100 kns
shelter as Tim more than a share I feel
no tears are necessary but I do look
forward to a celebration of his life on
Saturday April 12th from 1 to 4:00 at
Stonewall Farm in Keane thank
you do you have a
moment please rise for a moment of
silence and honor the former member of
Ming The Honorable Timothy Robins
for what reason is member rise Mr
Speaker I would move that the remarks of
the member from mbor be Perman printed
in the permanent journal without
objection thank you sir the house will
now attend to the consent
calendar Mr Speaker from the committee
on Municipal and County govern
government House Bill 123 removed by
Representatives kutab papovich Mueller B
turot Scully Perez Dian Kelly Tom Manion
seaworth and
Granger are there any other bills to be
removed from the consent
calendar representative Auborn moves
that the consent calendar with the
relevant amendments as printed in the
day's house record be adopted are you
ready for the question all those in
favor say I I those oppose nay the eyes
h of it have it and the consent calendar
is
adopted under the rules of the house the
committee on children and family law HB
493 is referred to the committee on
executive departments and administration
and HB 661 FN is referred to the
committee on finance from the committee
on karmas and consumer affairs
hb32 499 are referred to the committee
on Ways and Means HB
451 452 733 are referred to the
committee on finance and HB 538 FN is
referred to the committee on executive
departments Administration the committee
on education policy Administration HB
781 is referred to the committee on
finance the committee on fishing game
and resources HB 655 is referred to the
committee on criminal justice and Public
Safety the house will now attend to the
regular calendar
majority the committee on Commerce and
consumer affairs to which was referred
House Bill 639 FN act relative to the
use of and disputes over the blockchain
and digital currencies having considered
the same report the same with the
following Amendment recommendation that
the bill ought to pass with Amendment
sen of Carrie spear for the majority of
the
committee minority of the committee
having considered the same being unable
to agree with the majority Report with
the following resolution resolved that
is inexpedient to legislate
representative Merill Gibbs for the
minority of the
committee the amendment is
0445 H printed in house record 15 page
57-60 are you ready for the question on
the amendment all those in favor say I I
those oppose nay the eyes have it and
the amendment is adopted the motion
before us now is ought to pass with
Amendment are you ready for the question
all those in favor say I I those oppose
nay no the eyes have it and the
committee report is adopted and it's
going to
finance majority of committee on
criminal justice and Public Safety to
which was referred House Bill 59 FN act
relative to the assault of of a
firefighter emergency medical care
provider or law enforcement officer we
considered the same report the same with
the following Amendment the
recommendation to Bill ought to pass
with amendment of Mark proof for the
majority of the
committee minority of the committee
having considered the same being unable
to agree with the majority Report with
the following resolution resolved that
is inexpedient to legislate
representative Ray Newman for the
minority of the committee the amendment
is 05
59 printed in house record 15 pages
36 are you ready for the question on the
amendment all those in favor say I I all
oppose
[Applause]
nay division this is a clarification
division nobody in nobody out
the motion the motion before us is on
the amendment this is a division vote if
you're in favor you'll press the green
button if you're opposed you'll press
the red button voting stations are open
for 30 seconds
represent
quy represent leld
represent Freeman
repr
cyber represent MST here
C all members present have an
opportunity to vote also will attend to
stay to the
vote 190 voting a 172 voting a the
amendment is accepted the motion before
us now is ought to pass as Amendment the
chair recogniz as representative Ray
Newman thank you Mr
Speaker this bill is about assaulting
Public Safety
workers first I need to make it clear
that assaulting safety workers can never
be
tolerated and acknowledge the dangers
they face every
day testimony on this bill indicated
that it is intended to protect
so Public Safety workers from
assault we need to decide if this bill
provides the necessary protections they
deserve we also need to decide if it m
maintains protection for people who due
to mental or physical limitations are
experiencing the worst day of their
lives when dealing with First
Responders and they may be very
agitated we have no objective uh data
about the frequency of the crimes and we
are relying on anecdotal evidence about
that finally we need to decide if the
bill provides necessary tools to solve
this problem or is the better
solution mental health professionals
testified we need to slow this bill down
so we can give it give these decisions
full
consideration given the decisions
remaining the mar the minority committee
recommends House Bill 59 inexpedient to
legislate so another motion can be made
thank you Mr Speaker and I request a
division
vote chair recognized representative
roads chair recognized representative
roads oh okay do you
recognize good morning thank you Mr
Speaker so this
bill creates kind of
identifies that assaulting emergency
workers is a crime
we've heard in the past
that if someone does get charged with
assaulting an emergency worker whether
it's a firefighter EMS or police gone
before the judge and the judge says well
that's just part of your job suck it
up well I didn't notice that in my job
description was to get
assaulted on purpose we understand that
that mental health patients people with
disabilities will get hit by them when
they're having an
episode and I learned that early on in
my career I went to a nursing home for a
patient that was out of
control wiped out their day room we
finally got her calmed down sitting in a
chair we said we're going to take you to
the hospital she says I need my shoes I
said well let me put them on for you and
as I bent over she grabbed my hair was a
little bit longer than it is now right
and she would not let go the only way
she let go is she pulled it out and I
have a ball spot on the top of my head
to remind me every
day was I mad at her did I want her
arrested no because I knew she was in a
mental health
crisis we're trained we understand that
these people H act out they have no
control over it we're not looking at
that person we're looking at the person
who deliberately assaults us because
they're mad their family members called
them the police called us to come check
them
out just recently I had a coworker she
was climbing up into the back of the
ambulance the patient was on the
stretcher the patient looked at her gave
her that screwy you look and kicked her
Square in the face and knocked her out
the back of the
truck she said hey cops Sor it said n
we're not going to do nothing cuz the
judge's not going to do anything with it
this just tells the
judge it is a crime we're not looking to
be elitists we're not looking to make
this a hate
crime we just want people to know that
it's not okay we have repeat offenders
that we go into that house we wait for
the police cuz we know that they're not
happy with us for whatever reason
um so I ask that you support us and like
I said we're not looking to be special
but our job takes us to places that most
people don't want to go and deal with
people that most people don't want to
deal with but we do because it's our job
but getting beat up is not part of that
job on a regular basis part of it is but
it's for those special people that we
understand have no control and it's
knowingly and recklessly assaulting us
before anything can happen so we
appreciate your support and as much as I
hate to do this I want a roll
call represent appr has asked for a roll
call is that sufficiently
seconded it is sufficiently seconded
this will be a roll call vote members
take your
seats for
clear the motion before us majority
committer report of aass has amended
this is going to be a roll call
vote chair recognizes representative
Harriet goth for a parliamentary
inquiry thank you Mr
Speaker colleagues if I
know
that this is a duplication of laws that
are already in
motion and it also that the punishment
is first and second degree assault for a
firefighter and if I know that it
removes the reference to firefighters in
the current law about extended terms of
imprisonment
and if I know that the National
Association of mental
illness actually testified before us
that there was nothing carving out
anything for anyone that's having a
mental breakdown so if I
know
that so someone thinks that a
firefighter or somewhat law enforcement
or whoever it may be will make the
correct judgment on a person that
possibly could be a mental crisis I
would vote no r on this so that better
motion can be made thank you chair
recognized represent approv for
parliamentary
inquiry if I know that this law doesn't
change the penalties and make them any
worse than they
are and know so I also
know that even if a mental health
patient was arrested
when they got to court the judge would
say oh he's a mental health patient and
they would be go no
further and if I know that
if you want to support
us and keep us in the job
longer because if we get seriously beat
up we may not be able to return to work
and if I also know that it's very hard
to find
replacements for these jobs please Fire
EMS or any emergency worker please vote
green the motion before us committee the
majority committee report of a to passes
Amendment on House Bill 59 this is a
roll call vote if you're in favor you'll
press the green button if you oppose
you'll press the red button voting
stations are open for 30
seconds for
all members president had an opportunity
to vote house will attend to stay the
vote 196 voting y 179 voting a committee
report is adopted
chair recognizes the clerk for an
announcement thank you Mr Speaker Mr
Speaker this is just a reminder
announcement for the members of the
house pursuant to house rule 64 there is
no video recording from the membership
on the floor of the house uh the
sergeant-at-arms is authorized to
confiscate your phones if you do uh
violate the rules in that regard thank
you
majority of the committee on criminal
justice and Public Safety to which was
referred House Bill 87
FN an act prohibiting the posting of
land
not not owned by the poster having
considered the same report the same with
a recommendation that the bill ought to
pass representative Matt saorin Swan a
for the majority of the
committee the minority of the
committee having considered the same and
being unable to agree with the majority
a report with the following resolution
resolved that is inexpedient to
legislate sen of ler Harriet goth for
the minority of the committee the chair
recognizes representative Harriet
goth thank you Mr Speaker
this bill is brought forth without data
that shows that there's a problem in New
Hampshire it also uses terminology
that's not prudent in law
knowingly the bill requests for a first
offense a fine of 20 200 and any
subsequent offense
500 knowingly is
objective therefore if it would have
better been served as a first offense
possibly warning a second offense of 200
and therea the
500 the minor minority believed the
fines were excessive and thought about
the young person who was being foolish
and not thinking through their actions
may be affected by the by this new law
or the owner that never posted um the
land never
posted and not thinking wait a minute
lost my spot sorry the Landover private
property signs in the wooded area bottom
line this bill appears not to be a
solution to a problem but a bill looking
for a problem the methodology comments
State the bill provides penalties for
violations thus having an impact on the
judicial and the and possible
Correctional systems which may affect
prosecution incarceration probation and
parole cost for the state as well as the
county and local government so I would
appreciate if we really take a strong
look at this bill
and push
red J recognize representative
Roy thank you Mr Speaker that was that
was pretty complicated this is really
simple if you it's your property you get
a tax credit for keeping your property
open to hunting hiking all that if
someone say I don't know that doesn't
like hunting some
organization were to make a campaign
like they do and run around putting up
note hunting signs on your property what
should happen the other side says well
you know it might be some kids kids
aren't going around putting up no
trespassing signs I I don't recall that
as a hobby in high school so it's people
who are troublemakers and don't want
people hunting and they're infringing on
your right to have your property open so
it's a fine all right come on vree thank
you Mr M yeld to a question
yes member
yields thank you Mr Speaker thanks for
taking my question in your opinion um is
there any any chance of incarceration uh
written into this
bill
no a division has been requested members
take your seats
not yet
the motion before us is the majority
committee report of Auto pass on House
Bill 87 this is a division vote chair
recogniz representative Muse for
parliamentary inquiry
thank you Mr Speaker Mr Speaker if I
know that a per that a person caught
placing unauthorized signs on someone
else's property can already be charged
with criminal trespass and if I know
that inventing new crimes is something
we may want to think twice about at a
time when we have a shortage of police
officers who are already busy trying to
solve more important crimes that are
already on the books then would I press
the red button so another motion may be
made thank you chair recognize
representative Roy for a parliamentary
inquiry thank you Mr Speaker Mr Speaker
if I know to enforce trespass the person
has to be first noticed with no trespass
so if you don't catch them that's not
going to happen if I
further Mr Speaker if I know that to
enforce trespass laws you have to first
serve the person with a no trespass and
if I further know that if you own
property I don't care how small it's
dear to you and you want to keep it the
way you want to keep it I would vote
green the motion before us majority
committee report of Auto pass and House
Bill 87 this is a division vote if
you're in favor you'll press the green
button if you oppose you'll press the
red button voting stations are open for
30 seconds
[Music]
if all members present had opportunity
to vote house attend to state of the
vote 234 voting a 14 44 voting a the
committee report is
adopted majority crial majority of the
committee on criminal justice and Public
Safety to which was referred Health Bill
159 FN act authorizing the state to
report Mental Health Data for firearm
background check purposes providing for
the processes for confiscation of
firearms following certain mental health
court proceedings and for relief from
mental health related Firearms
disabilities having considered the same
report the same with the following
Amendment a recommendation that the bill
ought to pass with amendment of Terry
Roy for the majority of the
committee the minority of the
committee having considered the same and
being unable to agree with a majority
Report with the following resolution
resolve that is inexpedient to legislate
presed Matthew saborin D
cornair the amendment is 0487 H printed
in house record 15 pages 38 through 39
are you ready for the question on the
amendment all those in favor say I I
oppose nay no the eyes have it the
amendment is
adopted it's bills on second reading
open to further Amendment representative
Roy offers floor Amendment
0930 it's in your seat pockets is
recognized to speak to his
Amendment thank you Mr Speaker um I
should be able to cover everything in
this amendment without having to talk
again so you'll appreciate that this
amendment I listen to all of you um I
recognize the concerns that were there
from the members of this caucus and from
members of the House in general I
rewrote the entire bill for you I took
out there is not one word about
confiscation of weapons in this bill the
police are prohibited from confiscating
weapons in this pill I changed it so
that when you go to get your rights back
I put the burden on the state to prove
you're not ready to have your rights
back I changed it so that if you got out
from being committed and within in 90
days asked for your rights back they
can't order you to have another psych
Val because if they let you out you
should be better otherwise they
shouldn't have let you out this bill is
a total rewrite the only thing it does
that some still find objectionable and
that I can't get rid of because that's
the bill is reporting to NX we're one of
three or two or three states in the
whole country that don't do it we're
missing out on millions of dollars for
not cooperating and we're putting our
our citizens at grave risk in our law
enforcement if we know someone's
dangerous
after they've had a hearing and a trial
with a lawyer why would we on Earth want
them to be able to go buy a gun I ask
you to vote your conscience vote your
heart thank you very
much the motion before us is the Roy
floor Amendment
0930 are you ready for the question on
the floor of amendment all in favor say
I iose
nay the eyes have it and the floor
amendment is
adopted we now on to a to pass as
amended the chair recognizes
representative a Aris for speak against
the
Bill thank you Mr
Speaker Representatives I rise in
opposition to hb1 159 FN this bill has
errors of fact and law amendments cannot
fix it one more law will not change what
happened to Chief Bradley Haw if he had
been wearing a bulletproof Fest and
armed he'd be alive today the
bulletproof Fest would have allowed him
time to pull his weapon there are more
than 32,000 laws on the books meant to
prevent killings like this yet none of
them prevented the killing of Chief
Bradley
H bad guys don't read the laws bad guys
don't care Chief Bradley H was murdered
at dartman Hitchcock because their
policy was for disarming security
Personnel Chief H could have saved
himself if he has given the tools to do
so the state hospital now has Arm
Security in the
lobby the lobby entry where Bradley
House was murdered the hospital realized
they made a mistake and they are
responsible for the taking of his
life just
recently we learned that in Boston
Massachusetts an IR man with a knife
went into a Chick-fil-A tried to stab
two
patrons fortunately there was an
off-duty policeman there he identified
himself asked the mentally ill person to
put their weapon down and when he did
didn't he had and shot that person
dead across the pond England took
Firearms away from most of their
citizens the killings continued they
took away knives the killings continued
they then took away kitchen knives and
even said they should be blunted and not
sharp figure that one out and they took
away bats but the bill the killings
continued HP 159's promise the due
process is a joke do you really believe
you'll get relief from the Alcohol
Tobacco and Firearms Bureau I mean
seriously do we trust the
government once you're be in
order once you are in the nick system
you're not getting out the mentally ill
on Facebook post for Facebook for months
what they're going to do shooting up
schools whatever it is the major at Ford
hood that shot up his fellow soldiers
they were following these people you
want you don't have to disarm them what
you need to do is go get them and put
them in a hospital and get them
help in conclusion if firearm laws
worked Massachusetts New York and New
Jersey would be the safest in the
country but are
they no we just learned a 14-year-old
boy a 14-year-old boy in Newark killed a
police officer before he could even get
his seat Bel off and shot his partners
partners in critical conditions still
where'd he get the weapon from his
parents a relative no he bought it on
the streets there's 500 million Firearms
roughly out
there New Hampshire is one of two states
that doesn't have this law why because
we're a better state right we all know
that Massachusetts has the strictest
firearm laws in the country is Mass safe
I dare you to go spend the night on the
streets in lawren Mass good
luck and wrapping up New Hampshire is
different from the other states that's
why we're in the top three states for
just about everything in our great
country we are among the top three
states
economically personal freedoms and
safety including Firearms let's itl this
bill by pushing the red button thank you
very much chair recogniz represent L
sales thank you Mr Speaker and thank you
colleagues the opponents of this
bill tell you it's a red flag bill it's
not a red flag bill there's no red flag
Provisions in this the opponents of this
bill say it confiscates weapons it
doesn't confiscate
weapons the opponents to this bill says
you can't trust the government we are
the government
all right there's it's an they say it's
an Andy Second Amendment
bill it's not an anti Second Amendment
Bill 47
states have this provision how many have
rescinded it none of them how many have
have said that it's
unconstitutional because of the Second
Amendment none of them
are you
willing to sit there and vote against
this bill and have a crazy person get a
gun and shoot up a school or shoot up a
a bowling
alley or shoot their family or shoot
their neighbors or shoot
themselves crazy people should not have
guns I challenge
you if Bradley hos we don't know whether
Bradley hos would have been killed or
not we don't know that anybody that
tells you that is wrong so I ask
you grow a
pair vote for this bill because it's a
right thing to do thank you Mr Speaker
chair chair recognizes her
absent for what reason does a member
rise for motion Mr Speaker State your
motion uh this bill having just been
replaced by a floor amendment I move to
lay it on the table until at least after
lunch the motion is to table House Bill
159 a division has been called members
take your seats
the motion before us is to table House
Bill 159 this is a division vote chair
recognized representative Osborne for
parliamentary
inquiry thank you Mr Speaker if I know
that this uh bill was just Rewritten by
a floor Amendment and that there are a
number of no votes in the room who might
change their mind if we lay it on the
table for a while would I press the
green
button chair recognize representative
Roy for a parliamentary inquiry Mr
Speaker if I know that I wish it were so
that Minds would be changed I would
agree
but if I also know we need to just vote
and get this over with the public is
watching they want to know what we're
going to do on this and they want to see
what their representatives vote would I
vote no so that we can deal with it
motion before us is the table House Bill
159 to say division vote if you're in
favor you'll press the green button if
your opposer press the red button voting
stations are open for 30 seconds
[Music]
second all members present had an
opportunity to vote also attend to state
of the
vote 193 voting a 187 voting aay House
Bill 159 is laid on the
favor committee on criminal justice and
public Public Safety to which was
referred House Bill 183 act relative to
reporting requirements for Emergency
Medical Services Personnel consider the
same report the same with the
recommendation the bill ought to pass
repr Mark appr for the committee
representive Harriet goth has requested
a division vote members take your seats
the motion before us is ought to pass on
House Bill 183 this is a division vote
chair recognize represent approval for a
parliamentary
empery thank you Mr Speaker if I know
that this bill helps fire and EMS
departments with the unfunded Mandate of
making members
complete the report on routine calls
before they leave getting off duty and
paying
overtime and if I know that this bill
will allow departments to get more
complete information on some of the
calls that they weren't able to get it
right away because the patient was
incapacitate
incapacitated um would you please
support this Bill thank
you motion before us is ought to pass on
House Bill 183 that's a division vote if
you're in favor you'll press the green
button if you're opposed you'll press
the red button voting stations are open
for 30 seconds
[Music]
all members present had an opportunity
to vote El will attend to stay the vote
221 voting yay 158 voting a committee
report is adoped
majority of committee on criminal
justice and Public Safety to which was
fued House Bill 592 FN act relative to
magistrates and the standards applicable
to and the administration of bail having
considered the same report the same with
the following Amendment and a
recommendation that the bill ought to
pass with Amendment S Terry Roy from the
majority of the committee
minority of the committee having
considered the same being a to agree
with the majority Report with the
following Amendment the recommendation
that the bill ought to pass with
Amendment representative David M from
the minority of the
committee the majority committee
amendment is
044 8h printed in house record 15 pages
53 through
55 are you ready for the question a
division has been requested M members
take your seats
the motion be for us is the majority
committee Amendment
0448 H this is a division vote the chair
recognize representative Sher for a
parliamentary
inquiry if I know if I know that this
bill uh this amendment is costly to the
counties if I know that it will require
counties to hire more Corrections
Officers if I know that it will uh
strain the Judiciary even further uh
with costs uh if I know that this is as
anti-liberty a bill that there is and it
will result in many more people being
jailed uh and if I know that uh 25 to
30% of those people all people who are
charged with crimes 25 to 30% of them
have their charges either completely
dismissed or they are found not guilty
and if I know that because of
that we will be jailing pre-trial people
who have not who have not been found
guilty some of whom will never be found
guilty uh would I vote vote would I
press the red button and vote
no chair recognize representative oror
for a parliamentary agree uh thank you
Mr Speaker if I know that I want to
ensure that um protections for the
accused are codified would I support
this amendment rather than passing the
underlying bill without being amended by
pressing the green
button the motion before us is the
majority committee Amendment
0448 H it's in house record 15 printed
on pages 53-
55 this is a division vote if you're in
favor you'll press the green button if
you're oppos you'll press the red button
voting stations are open for 30 seconds
represent
priest represent Derby
all members present had an opportunity
to vote house will attend to state of
the
vote 209 voting a 167 voting a the
amendment is adopted bills on bills on
second reading open to further amendment
I would suggest everybody stay in your
seats we've got a number of amendments
to go through
bills on second reading open further
Amendment representative Shear moves
floor Amendment
09398 and that is in your seat
Pockets it is part of a stapled
group recognized represent
here thank you Mr Speaker uh if I know
well excuse me
um the current Amendment on the
amendment that was just approved is both
costly and it's
anti-liberty uh this amendment by
contrast uh recogniz es the work that
the criminal justice committee did last
session in a bipartisan fashion and
passed a bill uh 16 to0 uh that uh made
further tweaks to uh the bail Reform
Bill that was made tightened up the bail
Reform Bill and that that bill that bill
passed this house by an overwhelming
vote and it passed the Senate by an
overwhelming vote uh and what is now
before you simply tweaks that in a way
to uh to make it more tighten it up a a
good bit more
to force judges to
consider whether a person has a violent
past criminal record whether a person uh
the current charge is a a felony whether
the current charge is a violent felony
whether they're out on bail on a violent
felony or a felony of some sort that
this and this bill keeps in place the
magistrate system uh which uh allows
people who have been arrested to see a
magistrate or a judge within 24 hours
unlike uh the amendment that was just
passed which deletes uh the magistrates
completely and it allows for people to
be held individuals to be held for 36
hours excluding weekends and
holidays before they see a
judge uh which means somebody who's
arrested after uh 5:00 on a Friday may
not see a judge until the W following
Wednesday or
Thursday whether they even though
they've not been found guilty of
anything and even though 25 to 30% of
them will actually never be found guilty
uh
if what we need to understand is
everyone needs to understand in spite of
all the pr the bail system is
working
uh the mayor of Manchester told us on
Tuesday that the celebrated that the
crime rate in Manchester last year under
the last year's bail reform was down
15% that suggests and that isn't even
under the bill the bipartisan bill that
tightened up Bor form that didn't go
into effect until January 1st of this
year we don't need to fix uh we don't
need to fix bail reform we don't need to
fix bail reform because we know that
when bail form went into effect the year
bail reform went into effect there were
eight little over
18,000 violent crimes and property
crimes in New Hampshire that
year last year the last year it was it's
been documented under bail reform over
the last six years they're now only thir
only
13,000 plus property crimes or violent
crimes bail reform as this legislature
has continued to work on it is working
we do not need to throw it
out we need to tweak it as this
amendment does we need to reduce the
number of failures to appear uh that
will result in a judge uh presuming that
someone is not going to appear again
that is reduce it from three failures to
appear to two failures appear to appear
that is getting rid of uh substantially
the uh revolving door uh most
importantly this alternative does not
impose what is the equivalent of an
unfunded mandate on counties to hire
more Corrections
Officers uh to uh to open up wings of
jails that have been closed and used for
other purposes and uh what we know is
this amendment is not an anti-liberty
amendment it isn't jailing people uh
needlessly when uh by reducing the uh uh
uh uh the standard for which they can be
held to probable cause which is no
standard
whatsoever um we know that this uh this
Amendment will make the appropriate
tweaks to bail reform that the criminal
justice committee as it looks at how
bail reform is going under the new
provision which went into effect on
January 1st and we have time to consider
it this amendment will make a a a
worthwhile tweak but it will uh allow
the committee to continue to consider uh
this so I vot I urge you to vote uh yes
uh press the green vote excuse me press
the green button on this and vote Yes
and I ask for a division
vote chair recognize representative
rhs thank you Mr
Speaker so it's very interesting that my
colleague brings a floor Amendment and
says the words that we understand that
more tweaking can be done because last
term
whenever we sat there for a year and a
half working on this bail reform
reform the agreement that we agreed to
was because absolutely there was nothing
more can be done that was absolutely it
don't bring it back but yet we're told
in committee well yeah there is a little
bit more work can be done well you know
what we did do work and it's going to be
on the amendment that we're going to
pass after we kill this this floor
Amendment clear and convincing evidence
do you realize how high of a bar you
realize how high that is that's more
than what it takes to get a search
warrant additionally we aren't talking
about a person that is sadly not
vandalism or trespassing we're talking
about the 12 most egregious crimes we're
talking about child sex Predators we're
talking about people that have child
pornography on their computers we're
talking about people that are sexually
assaulting people and all the stars have
to align in like this this perfect
phenomenon you have to be arrested on a
Friday after
5:00 and Monday has to be a holiday
weekend that how many how many Monday
holidays do we have I I don't really
think that many
Additionally the bail Commissioners are
not allowed to hold bail hearings the
majority of the people are still going
to sorry magistrates are not allowed to
hold bail hearings the majority of
people are still going to see bail
commissioners
you know what they say the person in the
wrong always does the most
talking vote
red the motion before us now is the
sheer floor Amendment this is going to
be a division vote members take your
seats
get
the motion before us is the sheer floor
Amendment this is a division vote chair
recognizes representative Shear for a
parliamentary
inquiry thank you Mr Speaker if I know
that in do in February of this year
under the bipartisan bail Reform Bill
the police arrested a person and charged
him with seven felonies involving
narcotics
distribution and he was preventive
preventatively detained under the
bipartisan bail Bill if I know that in
Nashua a person was arrested for
repeatedly sexually assaulting a
15-year-old uh and and for manufacturing
child sexual abuse images and he was
preventive preventatively detained under
the bip Hardison bail Bill if I know in
Hudson a person the police arrested a
person for burglarizing a house and
putting in place hidden cameras to
record what the members of that house
were doing and he was held
preventatively uh under the current
bipartisan bail statute if I know in
that in Nashua uh representative this a
parliamentary inquiry not a speech uh
and if I know that in nashille the the
uh police arrested someone for shooting
someone during a fight and he was
preventively detained would uh I vote
press the Green Boat button and vote Yes
chair recognize representative rhs for a
parliamentary inquiry thank you Mr
Speaker Mr Speaker if I know that there
was just a KNE fight in Manchester a
couple weeks ago what I fight
red the motion be the motion before us
is a sheer floor Amendment it's in your
seat Pockets stay together in a packet
this is going to be a division vote if
you're in favor you'll press a green
button if you oppose you press a red
button voting stations are open for 30
seconds
represent
Walker while members present have an
opportunity to vote house will attend to
stay to the vote
171 voting a 209 voting a the amendment
fails bills on second reading open to
further Amendment pres Roy offers floor
Amendment
0948 it's in your seat pockets in the
packet the chair recognize
representative
Roy thank you Mr Speaker this is an
amendment actually um OS contacted me
notified me that there was a clerical
error this is all this does is fixes
reference in the statutes um please
support this
amendment the motion before us is the
Roy floor Amendment
0940 are you ready for the
question a division has been requested
members take your
seats doing a few against
the motion before us is the Roy floor
Amendment this is a division vote chair
recognized representative Shear for a
parliamentary
inquiry I know that this amendment
reinforces that the fact that people
will be held for 36 hours without seeing
a magistrate excluding or a judge with
excluding uh weekends and holidays uh
further up front to uh the liberty of
individuals uh without ever getting a
hearing before they've ever been found
guilty would I press the uh red button
and vote no chair recognized
representative Roy for parliamentary
inquiry thank you Mr Speaker if I know
that this amendment has nothing to do
with that stuff that he just said this
is just a a clerical correction would I
then just V vote to pass the amendment
so we could get to the
bill the motion before us is the Roy
floor Amendment
0940 printed it's in your seat
pockets and this is a division vote if
you're in favor you'll press the green
button if you oppose you'll press the
red button voting stations are open for
30 seconds
[Music]
represent elberg
all members president had an opportunity
to vote house attend to state to the
vote 206 voting day 173 voting a the
amendment is
adopted the motion before us now is
ought to pass as
amended roll call on House Bill
592 the chair recognizes representative
shear
thank you m thank you Mr Speaker um
you've heard a lot about Bale there's
been a lot of discussion over the last
many years uh let's not take a big leap
by just completely gutting uh the bail
reform statute that doesn't accomplish
what we want uh as has always in spite
of what uh uh earlier memb suggested we
have always been open on criminal
justice to listening to what's going on
and continuing to to tweak the bail Bill
we Perfection is never attainable and we
always listen to what's going on number
two I hesitate to talk about the
bleeping Manchester incident yet one
more time but that was a fight started
by one person he swung and hit another
person guy number two in the head called
him the nword and then the guy who was
hit in the head
said I got a knife let's not do this the
the guy number one says I got a knife
too even though he didn't have a
knife uh and so they come back together
again they tumble on the ground guy
number one uh gets nine stab wounds guy
number two gets two stab wounds the rule
on the street is he who wins a fight
gets charged uh and that's all the
happened uh guy number two is now
charged he's going to get a uh he's
going to raise a self defense claim and
it's a very strong self-defense claim so
what however you vote on this don't vote
based on that Manchester incident I gave
you examples of how many different times
the bail Statute in currently in place
has been working people are being held
preventively on a regular basis let's
not open the door the floodgates and
have a lot more people held uh when the
crime rate in Manchester has gone down
15% where the number of property crimes
has and violent crimes has gone down
from 18,000 to
13,000 uh since bail reform went into
went into effect it is working the
legislature has done an excellent job at
slowly and carefully adjusting bail
reform form issues when they come up and
it's been done on a bipartisan basis
let's continue with that and not you
take the opportunity uh to uh get rid of
bail reform as this uh bill this bill
does so I ask you to press the red
button uh and vote against vote no on
the
otpa thank you chair recognized
representative Roy
thank you Mr Speaker Mr Speaker this
isn't about you know who got stabbed or
who get arrested who let go this is
about policy the bill last year was a
good bill it wasn't a Republican bill
because we didn't have a republican
majority so we compromised and we came
up with a good
bill we don't have to
compromise it is now a republican Mor
majority and we're going to pass a
republican bail Bill we don't need to be
ashamed of that we're
Republicans and that's what we're going
to
do so I hate to say it but I have to
because someone famously said it
elections have
consequences vote for green the motion
before us
speak for what reason does a member rise
to make a motion State your motion uh I
move uh that we lay HP 59 2 on the
table it is a correct motion the motion
before us is to lay House Bill 59 and I
request 92 on the
table repesentative cutab has requested
a roll call is that sufficiently
seconded it is not sufficiently seconded
this will be a division
vote members take your seats this will
be a division vote
yes he is yeah yeah he is yeah
the motion before us is the table housee
bill
592 this is going to be a division vote
chair recognizes representative Sher for
a parliamentary
inory thank you Mr Speaker it's been a
while since I saw you all
um let's do what this legislature
does it's a parliamentary I know excuse
me I know that the right thing to do is
to do what we as legislators do best is
think carefully about things uh and uh
come to a consensus and come to
compromise so uh please press the green
vote button and vote Yes on the tabling
motion J recognized repr Barry for a
parliamentary inquiry thank you Mr
Speaker Mr Speaker if I know that this
is yet another attempt to protect the
broken bail law that we have in our
system and if Mr Speaker if I know that
our system doesn't work if I know that a
veteran an army veteran was killed on
Friday in the morning while he was
walking by a pond and he was stabbed to
death nine times by a person out on
double PR bail who was in who was on
bail for trying to stab someone and he
fulfilled that promise what I now put an
end to the games vote red so we can pass
this
bill also be order the motion before us
is the table House Bill 592 this is a
division vote if you're in favor you'll
press the green button if your opposer
press the red button voting stations are
open for 30 seconds
[Music]
represent while members present had an
opportunity to vote household tend to
stay the vote
177 voting aay 202 voting aay the motion
fails
okay representative grer has requested a
roll call as that sufficiently seconded
we're on the final vote of a to pass as
Amendment it is not sufficiently
seconded so the motion be the motion
before us is ought to pass as
amended on House Bill 592
we don't have
a
okay okay the division has been called
members take your seats
clear okay the motion before us is ought
to pass as amended
this is going to be a division vote
chair recognize representative sheer for
a parliamentary
inquiry I will be uh
uncharacteristically brief uh if I know
that the uh the this
otpa uh presents a bill that is both
costly to
counties uh and is anti-liberty in that
many people will be jailed some of whom
will never in spite of being found uh
not having been found guilty will never
be found guilty uh given the nature of
the system uh would I uh press the red
button and vote
no J recognize representative rhs for
parliamentary inquiry thank you Mr
Speaker Mr Speaker if I know that by
passing this bill we are going to go
back to where we were in before 2018
whenever we passed the disastrous Bill
Reform Bill there was a national effort
to fix something that was not broken in
the first place in New Hampshire and if
I know that by passing this we're going
to do do away with the magistrates that
don't have the ability to hold beer
healings in the first place and if I
know that only the most egregious Crimes
of the people are going to be held for
up to 36 hours whenever all the stars
line perfectly would I then press
green the motion before us is a to pass
as amended on House Bill 592 it's a
division vote if you're in favor you'll
press the green button if your appros
you press the red button voting stations
are open for 30
seconds for
[Music]
representative
Ames all members present had an
opportunity to vote house will attend to
state of the
vote 204 voting a 175 voting a the
committer report is
adopted and
it repres sentive Eric Johnson declared
a conflict and recuse himself from the
vote and this is going to
finance Mr
Speaker for
what I don't know who was first for what
reason does a member rise Mr Speaker I
would move to put the debate on House
Bill 592 in the permanent journal
without objection for what reason does a
member rise question for the chair Mr
Speaker on the last bill there were two
floor amendments ments but myself and
two of my seatmates could not find the
floor amendments in our seat
pockets they were stapled together in a
packet several of the amendments were
stapled together in the packet and it
I've been promised it will not happen
again for
the majority of the committee on
education funding to which was referred
House Bill 115 FN an act relative to
Universal eligibility for the education
Freedom account program having
considered the same report the same with
the following Amendment and the
recommendation that the bill ought to
you passed with Amendment representative
Rick lad for the majority of the
committee the minority of the committee
having considered the same and being
unable to agree with the majority Report
with the following resolution resolved
that it is inexpedient to legislate
representative David luno from the
minority of the committee
the majority committee amendment is
0651 H printed in house record 15 on
pages 36 to 37 the questions on the
adoption of the amendment are you ready
for the question all those in favor say
I I all those pose
nay the eyes have it and the Amendments
adopted the bills on second reading and
the house will be in
order the bills on second reading and
open a further Amendment
representative luno offers floor
Amendment
0916 H which can be found in your seat
Pockets
who representative luno is recognized
speak to the
amendment thank you very much Mr Speaker
this this is a simple Amendment and it's
directed to the income eligibility for
the school Voucher
Program unlike other Public Assistance
programs with income qualifications like
Medicaid like Snap and like the federal
school lunch program to make sure kids
are fed and ready to learn the state
school Voucher Program doesn't require
annual income
certification so what this amendment
does is apply an annual income
certification to the program to make
sure that every year at the present
level of about $110,000 a year for a
family of four that that the students
family is eligible for this public
assistance program it's that simple and
I hope we can all support this measure
to make sure that families who receive
this public assistant are in fact
eligible of course there's no more to do
to make up to make sure the money I'm
sorry of course there's more to do to
make sure the money is a good investment
for taxpayers such as making sure the
money is spent on educational goods and
services that lead to Strong student
outcomes and making sure that taxpayer
funds aren't being misappropriated like
what's happening in other states with
similar voucher
programs on Tuesday towns across the
state passed resolutions demanding
accountability to the EFA
program and urging legislatures not to
expand the program any further so
there's more to do but this is a good
conservative First Step so I hope you'll
support this Common Sense Amendment and
we can get out ahead of the state
auditor report that is due out later
this year and I think taxpayers will
want to know who's being responsible
because transparency is important to us
so I'd like to call for a roll call vote
thank you very much Mr
Speaker representative McDonald's
recognized speak against the
amendment thank you Mr
Speaker opponents have repeatedly filed
legislation to dismantle the EFA program
and this amendment is no different by
replacing the entire Bill leaving the
income gap in place and requiring
families to be recertified each year
this amendment forces children to switch
schools simply because their parents
income fluctuates from year to year also
this 11th Hour floor amendment was not
presented to the committee for
consideration despite there being ample
opportunities to do so the only thing I
agree with the previous speaker on is
that I would also like a roll call vote
so please press the red button thank
you representatives luno and McDonald
request a roll call is that sufficiently
seconded that is sufficiently seconded
this will be a roll call vote members
take your seats
I'll somebody
the questions on the adoption of floor
Amendment
0916 H this is a roll call vote
representative Ames is recognized for a
parliamentary
inquiry Mr speaker thank you um
if I know that this amendment requires
continuing annual
reconfirmation that each EFA recipient's
income remains below the statutory
income cap and if I know that the
current cap is adjusted each year to
keep up with
inflation and that this adjustment will
continue if this amendment is
adopted and if I know that that
adjustment occurs through the adjustment
in the annual uh setting of the poverty
uh level in the country and in this
region and if I believe reserving Public
Funding funded grants such as the EFA to
those
applicants with relatively low annual
income is good public
policy and knowing all of this would I
not then
push the green button to vote for this
amendment thank
you representative McDonald's recognized
for parliamentary
inquiry thank you Mr Speaker and Mr
Speaker if I know that this amendment
replaces the entire bill this amendment
has not been seen by the committee and
finally Mr Speaker if I know that this
amendment is a poison pill to the bill
would I now press the red buding so that
we could debate the underlying Bill
thank
you the questions on the adoption of
floor Amendment 0916 H this is a roll
call vote if you're in favor press the
green button oppose press the red voting
stations are open for 30 seconds
[Music]
representative read and page
of all members present had an
opportunity to vote the house will
attend to the state of the vote
170 and the affirmative 205 on the
negative the amendment
fails bills on second reading and open
to yet further
Amendment representative Ames moves
floor Amendment 0922 H which can be
found in your seat pockets and is
recognized to
speak okay hello again thank you Mr
Speaker um this is a simple Amendment
easy easy to understand it simply
applies to the EFA program the budgetary
restrictions and discipline of our
standard appropriation and spending
process it requires that there must be
appropriated and unobligated funds
available for each EFA
at the time of the determination and
decision on an applicant application for
an
EFA uh so it renders the EFA process
subject to the appropriation process
just as so many other uh parts of state
government and our state uh uh
system are uh also uh limited and
subject to the budgetary discipline
so please press the green button uh when
you get to calling of the vote and I do
Mr Speaker request a roll
call Representative Lads recognize to
speak against the
amendment well thank you very much Mr
Speaker it is
ironic sort of like catastrophic Aid if
there's not enough money appropriated
for for catastrophic Aid go back to the
education trust fund and get the money
necessary but you can't do it for an EFA
that's what they're trying to say
they're trying to say if it's not
appropriated but you have children in
your family are now going to come to
kindergarten and brother and sister
already in an EFA
program you're not going to get those
children in the EFA program either or
the new student moving into
town this is just another roadblock
another effort chip away at the EFA
program a program that has been
extremely successful I urge
you to vote no on this amendment thank
you representative Ames request a roll
calls as sufficiently
seconded as sufficiently seconded this
will be a roll call vote members take
your
seats e
[Music]
the questions on the adoption of floor
Amendment
0922 and this is a roll call vote
representative luno is recognized for
parliamentary
inquiry thank you very much Mr Speaker
if I know that on Tuesday voters from
all across the state uh voted
affirmatively to urge the legislature
not to expand this program then would I
press the green button to pass this
amendment to at least set a cap on this
wildly out of
control spending of taxpayer money thank
you representative Lads recognized for
parliamentary inquiry
thank you Mr Speaker if I know this
wildly exceptional program is very
successful and if I know this is the
best fit for so many children that have
been bullied that are in schools where
they're not receiving the academic
challenge they
deserve would I then vote to oppose this
amendment vot vote red
the questions on the adoption of
amendment
0922 this is roll call vote if you're in
favor press the green button opposed
press the red voting stations are open
for 30 seconds
[Music]
have all members present had an
opportunity to
vote the house will attend to the state
of the
vote 171 in the affirmative 205 and the
negative the amendment fails now on to
the main motion of a to pass as
amended representative L cler is
recognized speak against the committee
report Mr Speaker I rise today to ask
this body to protect the EFA program by
voting no on
hb15 for the current school year the
Year FAA program serves
5,321 students helping families to load
a moderate means provide an education to
their children proponents call this
program successful some even say wildly
successful the bill before us expands
the program moderately this year and
removes the income cap entirely next
year significantly expanding the fa
program now before its pending
performance audit is complete runs the
risk of putting a negative spot light on
the program and harving its long-term
solvency while the concept of universal
EFS is popular nationally the taxpayers
we represent here in New Hampshire
aren't so sure the grant State taxpayers
our longest running taxpayer advoc
advocacy organization opposed this bill
telling the education funding committee
that quote expanding an existing program
at a time when a budget deficit looms
and even human services phas Cuts is
inappropriate
end quote putting aside disagreement
over what the expansion in this bill
will cost taxpayers the majority report
States this bill will cost 11 million in
new money in the second year once the
income cap is removed we all know the
spending and revenue crunch our state is
under right now and that that there is
no extra money available to expand the
programs we
support in the finance committee there's
been talk of increasing fees to help
balance the budget and the government's
budget itself includes signific
significant increases on
developers the governor's budget doubles
fees on Excavating and dredging doubles
fees on applications for Shoreline
terrain alterations and even raises the
fees on the registration of
dams we have choices to make wouldn't it
be nice to pass a budget with no
increased fees instead of spending 11
million helping people who are generally
well off and able and already pay for
the uh private education themselves
shouldn't we be holding the line on
taxes and fees and working to keep costs
down on the businesses we need to solve
our housing crisis remember we don't
need this bill to expand the EFA program
the governor's budget expands efas in a
revenue neutral way providing Universal
choices to students who public school is
not working for let's not risk a good
thing by spending money that we just do
not have please join me in pressing the
red button against the OTP thank you Mr
Speaker represent McDonald's recognized
speak in support of the committee
report thank you Mr Speaker honorable
colleagues I look forward to the day
when children will no longer be turned
away from education because of their zip
code or their fam's inability to pay by
providing school choice to every New
Hampshire Family House Bill 115 5 FN
guarantees children will never be turned
away
again so I rise again today in support
of the committee report as a product of
public schools and even as a recent
graduate of a public high school here in
New Hampshire but education should not
be a onesize fits-all approach because
one siiz does not fit
all therefore we should celebrate
students differences rather than erase
them furthermore this bill empowers
students to Excel and to exceed
Expectations by expanding education
Freedom accounts
efas
universally first the maximum eligible
annual income would increase in fiscal
year 2026 and better yet be completely
eliminated in all subsequent years this
change levels the playing field because
means testing is not required for
admission to Public Schools under
current law the same should be true for
all educational Pathways including the
EFA program which despite what we are
often told is not a voucher program in
addition to this blade and lie we often
hear three other misconceptions about
EFA
expansion number one efas can only be
spent on private school tuition to the
detriment of public schools
wrong current EFA participants also
learn online in homeschool programs and
even in New Hampshire's Public School
schools number two the EFA program lacks
accountability
Ron the awardwinning nonprofit who
administers the program has made both an
itemized list of expenditures and an
audit report publicly available for
anyone to
review number three EFA expansion
increases local property taxes Ron
again the EFA program is funded by the
state education trust fund and has
already returned more than
266 million tax dollars to tax
payers finally today the other body is
also considering so-called Universal EFA
expansion however the other body's Bill
merely exchanges the income limitation
under current law for limitations on the
total number of
students so their bill is a step
backwards and this bill is a step
forwards so please join the resounding
84% of parents the majority of the
committee and myself in supporting our
youngest constituents via House Bill 115
FN thank you and Mr Speaker I request a
roll call vote please
roll call Mr Speaker the question is on
the majority committee report about to
pass as amended representative Luna
requests a roll call which looks like
it's sufficiently seconded this will be
a roll call vote members take your
seats e
the questions in the majority committee
report about to pass is amended on House
Bill 115 this is a roll call vote
representative Damon recognized for
parliamentary inquiry
thank you Mr Speaker good morning
colleagues if I know that providing
Universal education Freedom accounts
means paying for children of affluent
families who are already in private
schools at a cost of over $100 million
per year and if I know that the New
Hampshire EFA program lacks outcome
measures but similar programs in other
states have shown dismal outcomes and if
I know that this legislation fails to
meet our basic obligation to fiscal
responsibility for the taxpayers we all
represent during a time of a looming
budget crisis would I now press the red
button to defeat this extreme expensive
irresponsible legislation thank
you representative lad's recognized for
parliamentary
inquiry thank you very much Mr
Speaker if I know New Hampshire's cost
per pupil has dramatically increased
producing a perfect inverse correlation
of plummeting educational
scores and if I know those parents
seeking a better fit for their children
deserve this opportunity to attend a
school where they can achieve and
accomplish their
goals if I know projected costs for the
EFA program contain in
hb15 are much less than the exaggerated
$100
million that have been incorrectly
exaggerated by the
opposition and lastly and perhaps more
important for public throughout this
country if I know hb15 sends a clear
message to the education consumer to
shop
around competitive and successful
educational Choice options are now
available in New hampsh
thank
you yeah and press that beautiful green
button and remember it's like Jeopardy
put it in the form of a
question the questions on the majority
committee report about to pass is
amended on House Bill 115 this is a roll
call vote if you're in favor press the
green button oppose press the red voting
stations are open for 30 seconds e
[Music]
of all members present had an
opportunity to vote the house will
attend to the state of the
vote 198 in the affirmative 180 in the
negative the committee report is adopted
representative cab declared a conflict
and recused herself from the votes on
this
bill House Bill 115 is referred to the
committee on finance
for what reason does a member rise to
make a
motion I'm sorry to make a motion yeah
go ahead uh I move that the debate on
hb15 be printed in the permanent Journal
oh I don't think there'll be any
objection to
that representative Alexander is
recognized for a lunchtime
announcement thank you Mr Speaker um um
the housing committee will meet for a
brief executive session in lob 305 right
now to exec our final three bills 296
410 and 457 see you
there the house will be in recess until
p.m.
e
e e
chair recognizes rep representative
lelis for what reason does a member rise
to make a motion Mr Speaker State your
motion Mr Speaker I've heard from
numerous people people who said that
because of the floor Amendment they
completely changed the
bill heard from numerous people
including members of the leadership that
they needed more time to digest that
floor Amendment so Mr Speaker I move we
take HB 159 FN off the
table the motion is to remove
representative katab has requested a
roll call is that officially
seconded it is not sufficiently seconded
this will be a division
vote e
Rich go first
the motion before us is to remove House
Bill 159 from the table this is a
division vote the chair recognizes rep L
Salis for a parliamentary
inquiry thank you Mr speaker thank you
colleagues if I know that everybody had
a a little bit of heartburn about having
such a big floor Amendment and that
didn't have time to digest it so would
you now press that big green button to
take it off the table so that the so
that we can vote on the bill as a whole
thank
you chair recognize representative
Osborne for a parliamentary
inquiry uh thank you Mr Speaker if I
know that I have yet to hear from anyone
who changed their mind on this vote and
I know that it's laying on the table
right now without a roll call vote and
I'd like it to just stay there uh would
I press the red button the motion before
us is to remove House Bill 159 from the
table this is a division vote if you're
in favor you'll press the green button
if you're oppose you press the red
button voting stations are open for 30
seconds
[Music]
represent
love all members present have an
opportunity to vote how will attend to
stay the
vote 174 voting a 198 voting
a I'll spill 159 say is on the
table recognize the clerk for messages
Mr Speaker I have two messages uh from
chairs pursuant to house rle
47f uh chair uh Roy of Criminal Justice
waves the second committee referral of
House Bill
655 and from the committee on finance
pursuant to house rule 47f uh the chair
of Finance um waves the referral of
House Bill 451
the majority of committee on education
funding to which was referred House Bill
319 FN act relative to the
responsibility of local school districts
to provide transportation and meals for
pupils in kindergarten consider the same
report the same with the following
Amendment and the recommendation the
bill ought to pass with amendment of Dan
McGuire from the majority of the
committee minority of the committee on
Ed uh the minority of the committee
having considered the same and being
unable to agree with a majority a report
with the following resolution resolve is
inexpedient to legislate sen of Hope
Damon for the minority of the committee
the amendment is
0345 H printed in house record 15 page
42 are you ready for the question on the
amendment all those in favor say I I
those oppose nay the eyes have it and
the amendment is adopted the motion
before us now is ought to pass with a
Amendment the chair
recognizes the chair recognizes
representative
Richie thank you Mr
Speaker in 2007 the New Hampshire
legislature required school districts to
offer at least part-time kindergarten we
C we passed this because we know that
kindergarten is valuable to the
cognitive behavioral and Social
Development and reduces chances of
special education services needed in
later
grades all children need an equal
opportunity to
succeed because kindergarten is not
mandatory transportation for Mid midday
kindergarten is a barrier that if not
provided by the school district can
cause many children to forego attending
kindergarten midday train transportation
is especially important for Working
Families if midday transportation is not
provided caregivers would have to leave
their jobs to see to the safety of their
children or their child would not attend
kindergarten those families that have to
leave their job would put an undue
strain on the finances of these
families we don't want to disadvantage
any of our
children excuse me sorry
please press the red button on
otpa and Mr Speaker for the sake of
transparency I request a roll call thank
you chair recognize representative Dan
Maguire thank you Mr Speaker um this
bill simply removes a mandate that
schools provide transportation to
halfday kindergarten
students um I'll just give you an
example of why why this is important
suppose you had an elementary school
that offers half day
kindergarten um and let's say it had a
half a dozen bus routes so a normal
student uh in other grades um does one
Loop of the bus every day right they go
in on half of the loop and come back on
the other half of the loop but a halfday
kindergarten student can take the bus in
if they're in the morning half right so
they're in one of two classes the
morning class or the afternoon class and
if they're in the morning class they can
take the regular bus into school no
problem if they're in the afternoon
class they can take the regular bus home
again no problem but if there uh but the
problem comes for the morning students
going home and the afternoon students
coming in why because they're a tiny
fraction of the whole school and so
either you're going to send six almost
empty buses around on those six routes
but what usually happens is you get one
bus still mostly empty and it has to go
not just on each individual route but it
has to go all over the whole town right
so the length of the ride for these
midday kindergarten students is
extremely long right and so um these
younger kids it's it's um uncomfortable
and and not appropriate to to send them
on these on these long rides
and so these kids are ones that need
adult supervision for most of the day
anyways right because they're only in
school half the day so it's not too big
of an of an ask to let the adult who's
going to take care of these kids give
them transportation for the for the
middle of the day so it's just an option
for school districts if school districts
want to provide this Transportation they
can if they have a small District they
might very well do that but for some of
these uh districts with long bus routes
this is a um a little simple Improvement
and less of a mandate so please press
the green button thank
you R has requested a roll call is that
sufficiently
seconded it is sufficiently seconded
this will be a roll call vote members
take your
seats e
the motion before us is ought to pass
that as amended on House Bill 319 this
is a roll call vote chair recognize the
representative Chan for a parliamentary
inory thank you Mr
Speaker if I know that without school
districts providing transportation for
kindergarten students many families will
not be able to get the children to
kindergarten and if I know from my
life's dedicated work that kindergarten
attendance is one of the bre best
predictors of success in
school what I now press the red button
to oppose this unfair bill
chair recognize represent of Amman for a
parliamentary
inquiry thank you Mr
Speaker Mr Speaker if I know that this
bill removes an unfunded mandate that
school districts must provide
transportation for halfday kindergarten
students traveling to or from
school and if I also know the midday
Transportation requirement may add
approximately $75,000 to a school budget
each each year including in my town New
Boston to run a couple of partially
filled
buses would I then leave policymaking
regarding how children are best
transported to and from school for half
day kindergarten to the local school
board and community and also press the
green button thank you the motion before
us majority committee report of a passes
amend on House Bill 319 this a roll call
vote if you're in favor you'll press the
green button if you oppos you press the
red button voting stations are open for
30 seconds
get
[Music]
represent
Harington represent
Baldwin all members president had an
opportunity to vote house will attend to
state of the vote
vote 204 voting aay 171 voting aay
committee report is
adopted the majority committee on
education funding to which was referred
House Bill 527 FN act replacing the
Statewide education property tax with a
local Revenue contribution
consider the same report the same with
the following resolution resolve that is
an inexpedient to
legislate representative Daniel papichi
Mueller for the majority of the
committee minority of committee having
considered the same being unable to
agree with the majority report the
recommendation the bill ought to pass
represented Sally fellows from the
minority of the
committee the motion before us is
inexpedient to legislate and House Bill
527 FN are you ready for the question
all those in favor say I I Clos n the
eyes have it and committee report is
adopted committee on education funding
to which was referred House Bill 563 FN
act relative to adequate education grant
amounts for pupils receiving special
education services considered the same
report the same with the following
Amendment the recommendation that the
bill ought to pass with Amendment sen
Rick lad for the committee the amendment
is
0650 printed in house record 15 pages
46- 48 are you ready for the question on
the amendment all those in favor say I I
those oppose nay the eyes have it the
amendment is adopted the motion before
us now is ought to pass with Amendment
are you ready for the question all those
in favor say I iose nay the eyes have it
and the committee report is adopted
it's
also and it it also headed to
finance the majority of committee on
education funding to which was referred
House Bill 646 FN local act requiring
school districts to establish an online
application for participation in the
free and reduced price meal program
having considered this same report the
same with the following resolution
resolved that is inexpedient to
legislate Senator Rick lad for the
majority of the
committee minority of the committee
having considered the same being unable
to agree with a majority Report with the
following Amendment recommendation that
the bill ought to pass with Amendment
representative Tony Weinstein for the
minority of the
committee chair
recognizes chair recognizes
representative Weinstein
jump in the thank you Mr
Speaker HB 646 is a crucial step in
tackling food
insecurity as of September 2024 39% of
New Hampshire children were living in
households that reported food
insecurity and we know that thousands of
Granite State children eligible for free
and reduced School meals aren't enrolled
in the program HB
646 ensures that more students will have
access to free or reduced price Meals by
offering both online and physical
application
options this addresses barriers such as
language differences Transportation
issues and the stigma associated with
paper
forms by simplifying and expanding the
application process more families can
receive the support they need and when
they and when they need it ensuring
children don't go hungry and enabling
them to thrive in their learning
environments and I emphasize Thrive
because increased access to nutritious
meals help students Focus reduces
absenteeism and improves overall
well-being and academic
performance by introducing an accessible
and userfriendly online platform HB 646
modernizes the meal application process
making it more efficient for both
families and school
administrators this One-Stop resource
simplifies the system reduces
administrative burdens and speeds up
eligib eligibility
determinations benefiting both
applicants and school nutrition
programs the bill also provides
administrative and technical assistance
to school districts in ensuring all
districts regardless of size or budget
can implement the online application
system
effectively this support helps maintain
consistency reduces paperwork and
enhances efficiency in processing
applications I urge my colleagues to
vote against the itl motion so that a
motion of OTP with a fiscally
responsible amendment can be considered
and I request a roll call vote
chair recognized representative
lad thank you very much Mr
Speaker as a school building principal
for years and years I can remember
sitting down and receiving these
applications back from students are you
going to be taking advantage of the free
and reduced program yes or no and all
that information would be filled out and
it's an important process seeing that
many of our programs within the ad
funding formula including even it
reaches this over into the Career
Technical education format uh depend
upon and utilize issues associated with
poverty
however this program right here that's
being proposed today requires every
District to have an online application
as well as the paper process we
currently
use in asking my school district what
are you using they're saying we're
already using an online app ation
process we went ahead and developed
ourselves and we're getting an increased
number of students that are
participating in the f&r
program so with
that there's a district that did it
without another statutory requirement or
unfunded requirement comes down from onh
high but secondly on this bill it
requires the Department of Education to
hirees people that are going to help
with administrative and Technical
Services that comes up to over the next
bium FY 26 and 27 a couple hundred th000
and it's probably a little bit more than
that seeing that it would be a several
people but on top of that we have to
allocate another $1 million for the
application the software package to make
this curve from the state
level with school districts already
having the opportunity to do this and
doing it then I see this bill is not
necessary thank you very much and I
would press the green button
motion before us majority committee
report of index speak to legislator on
House Bill
646 representative luno has requested a
roll call is that sufficiently
seconded it is sufficiently seconded
this will be a roll call vote members
take your seats
yes
motion before us a majority committee
report of any speak to legisl and House
Bill 646 this is a roll call vote chair
recognized representative for a
parliamentary
inquiry thank you Mr
Speaker if I know that just last week
this body voted to make it more
difficult for 10,000 students to receive
free and reduced meals and I know that
feeding students adequately reduces
special education costs and I know that
passing this bill will allow those
students and families to have a method
to conveniently apply for those
nutritious meals would I now press the
red button to overturn the itl so that
an OTP May be put forward thank you
chair recognize represent Columbia for a
parliamentary
inquiry thank you Mr Speaker Mr Speaker
if I know this bill requires school
districts to establish an online
application for participation in the
free and reduced price meal program and
if I know some districts already have
developed and implemented the online
application without the need for
legislation and last ly Mr Speaker if I
know this program would require the
department to provide Technical and
administrative assistance at the cost of
$26,000 with an additional appropriation
of 1 million for software for the
upcoming bium would I then press green
the green button thank you Mr
Speaker the motion before us is the
majority commit report of any expedient
to legislate on House Bill 646 this is a
roll call vote if you're in favor your
press the green button if your opposer
press the red button voting stations are
open for 30
seconds represent
[Music]
L all members president had an
opportunity to vote house will attend to
state of the
vote 209 voting day 165 voting committee
report is
adopted majority committee on education
funding to which was referred House Bill
675 FNA local an act increasing the
total revenue raised under the Statewide
education property tax requiring
municipalities to remit excess Statewide
education property tax payments to the
Department of Revenue Administration
limiting the authority of school
districts who make certain
Appropriations and increasing base
adequacy cost per pupil having
considered the same report the same with
the following Amendment and the
recommendation the bill ought to pass
with Amendment sen Dan Maguire from the
majority of the
committee minority of the
committee having considered the same and
being unable to agree with a majority
Report with the following resolution
resolve that is inexpedient to legislate
sen of Hope Damon for the minority of
the
committee the amendment is
0548 H printed in house record 15 pages
61-
62 for what reason does a member rise
it's make a motion State your motion I
move that we lay HB 675 upon the
table that is a proper motion so the
motion before us is to lay House Bill
675 on the on the table and a division
has been requested
motion before us it's the L House Bill
675 on the table this is a division vote
chair oriz representative Jam for a
parliamentary
inquiry thank you Mr Speaker if I know
that this bill dictates to local school
districts not just how much they can
spend but also the formula they must use
and if I support local control and I
believe that my colleagues in this body
do too would I then press the green
button to lay the bill upon the table
thank you chair recognize representative
Osborne for a parliamentary inquiry
thank you Mr Speaker um if I know that
and we all know that property taxes are
out of control if I know that uh this
measure before us is probably the most
important one that we have all year
maybe to protect our taxpayers uh would
I now press the red button and not lay
this on the
table the motion before us is to lay
House Bill 675 on the table this is a
division vote if you're in favor you'll
press the green button if you oppose you
press the red button voting stations are
open for 30 seconds for
[Music]
all members present had an opportunity
to vote house will attend to stay to the
vote 187 voting yay 189 voting nay
motion
fails the question we're back on to the
question on the amendment are you ready
for the question all those in favor say
I I
oppose
nay division has been called members
take your
seats this is a clarification
vote all right this this vote is for
clarification purpose purposes so if
you're in favor of the amendment you'll
press the green button if you're oppos
you'll press the red button voting
stations are open for 30 seconds
represent
bernardy all members present and an
opportunity to vote how attend to stay
the
vote 204 voting a 17 three voting a the
amendment is
adopted the motion before us now is a to
pass with Amendment the chair recognizes
representative
Damon thank you Mr
Speaker HB 675 is one of the more
significant locally impactful bills of
this legislative session as amended its
sole purpose purpose is to impose a
state mandated cap on school budgets
based on the 5-year average of
previously approved amounts adjusted by
enrollment percentage change and the
Consumer Price Index the amendment
removed the swept Provisions in the
original
Bill along with completely overriding
local school districts control over
their budgets this legislation
perpetuates the existing and very
significant funding inequities between
districts current spending per student
largely D driven by the wide differences
in property wealth ranges from 177,000
to 44,000 per student per year imposing
a state budget cap means that districts
with less resources would continue to be
locked into those limited budgets since
the passage of s SP 383 last year
districts already have a mechanism to
vote locally to create a budget cap that
process aligns much more with our New
Hampshire value on local control and in
fact this week not a single school
budget cap passed uh on town meeting day
local voters
spoke it is critical to recognize that
when there is a significant increase in
special education funding in a district
with a budget cap those student services
will be provided as mandated by federal
law resulting in much reduced funds for
the general education population
there is no predicting Future Special
Education costs as Simply Having a child
move into the district could have
significant financial impact all
students deserve to have quality
education fairly
funded what happens if the utility costs
for a district especially those with
many facilities rise in response to
world events tariffs or weather events
again the district would be forced to
cut funding for Education Service
to cover basic operating costs the
proponents of this bill choose to
believe that permitting a 2third
majority vote to override the state
imposed budget cap is sufficient
flexibility but we all know the reality
that 2third votes are very rarely
successful clearly the authors of this
legislation intended to have permanent
impact HB 675 is an arbitrary
Sledgehammer that attacks local control
without any flexibility reason or
fairness it completely violates New
Hampshire's longtime respect for local
control by overriding school districts
HB 675 would cause irreparable harm to
communities lacking property wealth
please join me in defeating the otpa so
a better motion that respects our local
voters and supports adequate education
for all students regardless of zip code
can be put forward press the red button
thank you chair recognizes represent Don
Dan
Maguire thank you Mr
Speaker It's Perfectly Natural to think
that spending is correlated with quality
when you buy a a shirt if you spend more
you get a nicer shirt you buy a car you
spend more you get a nicer car a house
everything most of life is like that but
strangely this simply isn't true in New
Hampshire schools
um if you if you look at um spending
versus standardized test scores there
are schools that um spend as little as
$133,000 a child and others that spend
is over $30,000 a child but in both
categories there are schools that
perform much better than average and
schools that perform much worse than
average now all this data is kept by our
department of
Education um but but a good place to to
visualize this um is I'll give you a
website it's uh Georgetown University
School of public policy has a website
called edunom lab.org Ed
nomics lab.org if you go there and
scroll down to Scatter Plots you'll and
then select on New Hampshire you'll see
a graph that has a a data point for
every school in New Hampshire and you
can move your mouse over the over the uh
data points and find your own school if
you want but basically this graph in the
horizontal axis is money and the
vertical access is Axis is test scores
and it looks like a PO polka dot shirt
or a case of measles or something like
that there is no correlation between
spending an
outcome okay but what we do know is that
there's a huge correlation between
spending and property
taxes
right um our taxpayers have been
burdened with ever Rising School
spending over the last 10 years up
58% uh when inflation is more like 30
35 okay um and at the same time
employment uh enrollment has
declined and and uh performance is
stagnant to
negative okay so HB
675 pauses that spending growth to let
cat taxpayers catch their
breath um it only allows spending to
rise if the student population is rising
so it doesn't cut anything
right it just doesn't allow spending to
increase unless student population
increases and even then the if if a a
locality wants to spend more they can
override the cap with a two3
vote okay so please press the green
button to help your constituents by
pausing Rising property taxes thank you
Mr Speaker
the motion before us is majority
committee report of aut of pass as
amended representative Damon has
requested a roll call as that
sufficiently
seconded it is sufficiently seconded
this will be a roll call vote members
take your seats
ask
the motion before us majority committee
report of autop pass as amended on House
Bill
675 this is a roll call vote chair
recognizes representative luno for a
parliamentary
inquiry thank you very much Mr Speaker
if I know that all year long voters from
all across the state have resounded
rejected local budget
caps and if I know that it's really time
for this legislative body to listen to
the voters and they're out there
watching and they're going to hold us
accountable then wouldn't I now press
the red button to defeat this terrible
measure thank you chair recognize
representative or one for parliamentary
inquiry thank you Mr speaker so if I
know that property taxes are out of
control control if I know that these
property taxes are decided by local
elections and if I know that all year
long including just this week the voter
turnout in these local elections is only
less than
15% and if I know that when 7.5% of my
neighbors all get together and decide to
take my house that that is not local
control that is a tyranny of Fringe
special interests would I now press the
green button and protect our
taxpayers the motion before us the
majority committee report of autop pass
as amended on House Bill house will be
in
order on House Bill
675 this a roll call vote if you're in
favor you'll press the green button if
you're oppose you press the red button
Vol voting stations are open for 30
seconds
[Music]
Walker
all members present had an opportunity
vote house will attend to stay to the
vote 190 voting a 185 voting a committee
report is
adopted and it's going to finance
jority committee on education funding to
which was referred House Bill 703 FNA
local act relative to prohibiting school
districts from denying meals to students
with unpaid meal balances and making an
appropriation therefore having
considered the same report the same with
a following resolution resolved that is
inexpedient to legislate representative
Raymond peoples for the majority of the
committee
minority of the committee having
considered the same being unable to
agree with the majority Report with the
following Amendment the recommendation
Bill ought to pass for amendment of Hope
Damon for the minority of the
committee chair recognizes
representative
Damon representative
Damon
sorry thank you Mr
Speaker I Rise to ask my colleague
colleages to reach deeply for kindness
and empathy and please join me in
defeating the itl for HB
703 I hope that we all believe that
every child deserves the opportunity to
learn to thrive and that no child should
go hungry during the school day this
bill prohibits schools from denying
meals serving alternative lesser meals
or stigmatizing students based on their
meal payment status it also would
require require school districts to
accept voluntary donations to alleviate
School Mill debt which addresses an
issue that occurred last year in New
Hampshire an amendment that would make
the bill budget neutral by removing the
requirement for the Department of
Education to pay for District School
Meal debt is ready for your attention as
such HB 703 is then simply asking
districts to have a clear policy that
protects our students from being shamed
for their economic state status 39% of
New Hampshire children over 1third live
in households who have insufficient food
access children living with food
insecurity are twice as likely to
receive special education services twice
as likely to repeat a grade have
increased hyperactivity and difficulty
focusing and are twice as likely to be
suspended which also interferes with
learning children are not not
responsible for their
poverty let me say that again children
are not responsible for their
poverty yet we know that when students
are labeled for being poor they often
choose to go hungry rather than be seen
getting a meal that stigmatizes them
using tokens stickers stamps a published
list of students with meal debt
alternative meals prohibiting
extracurricular or field trip
participation or requiring students to
do chores to earn their meals are all
ways that we call out children for
poverty my mom was a hardworking food
service director and I know most
nutrition and kitchen School staff are
compassionate wonderful people but
sometimes policies are created that are
not kind wonderful and fair to
students access to the school meals
program is strongly associated ated with
improved education and health benefits
including less childhood obesity it is
associated with reduced absenti ISM and
tardiness and fewer behavioral issues
School Meal programs have to balance
offering foods that are appealing to
today's children with providing
nutritionally sound meals many items
served in the school meal program are
required by federal rules to meet
nutrition standards that are much
healthier than the same item you could
purchase in the store or at a restaurant
you cannot tell the amount of nutrition
provided by the name on a
menu the minority recognizes that it is
essential to Children's educational
success to be fed adequately and
routinely please join me in voting
against the itl so a better Kinder
motion can be made for our kids thank
you chair recogniz representative
peoples
thank you Mr
Speaker this bill requires school
districts with meal programs to adopt
meal policies that do not deny or Stig
stigmatized students with unpaid meal
balances this Builder Bill further
authorizes the school to complete the
application for free meals a right that
should stay with the parent or
Guardian by allowing meal debt to go un
checked and eliminating all forms of
collection puts a burden on the taxpayer
to pick up the cost School nutrition
programs are to our students and why we
can all agree that no student should be
denied a meal for any reason we also can
agree that it's unfair to dump that bad
debt onto the taxpayer this is an issue
that's best handled at the local level
allowing local districts control over
the policies that govern their school
lunch programs I would urge you to
support the recommendation for
it the motion before us majority to
commit a report of inexpedient to legis
St on House Bill 703 representative lunu
has requested a roll call is that
sufficiently
seconded it is sufficiently seconded
this will be a roll call
vote e
the motion before us the majority
committee report of inexpedient to
legisl House Bill 703 this a roll call
vote chair recognize representative
Weinstein for a parliamentary
inquiry thank you Mr Speaker Mr Speaker
if I know that there are students in New
Hampshire schools who are stigmatized by
poverty and are facing food insecurity
and if I know that those students
shouldn't be subjected to meal shaming
practices like denying meals serving
alternative meals or stigmatizing
students based on their meal payment
status and I know that this bill
addresses that by simply asking school
districts to adopt compassionate
policies then would I now press the red
button to defeat the itl motion so that
a better motion can be made thank you
chair recognize representative lad for a
parliamentary
inquiry thank you very much Mr Speaker
if I know the amount of meal debt
accured at the local level is estimated
by the department to be as much as $2.5
million
annually and if we all know that no
child should be denied a meal for any
reason however if I also know that by
allowing meal debt to be unchecked and
then requiring the Department of
Education to pay the UN paid meal debt
it would unfairly shift the burden of
debt responsibility onto local
taxpayers would I then leave the
management of Local School Meal programs
to the Local District and press the
green button and itl this bill the
motion before us a majority committee
report of inexpedient to legislative
House Bill 703 this is a roll call vote
if you're in favor you'll press the
green button if you're oppos you press
the red button voting stations are open
for 30 seconds is
all members present had an opportunity
to vote also attend to state of the
vote 202 voting aay 173 voting a
committee report is
adopted
speaker for what reason do the member
rise
may I ask that the debate on House Bill
703 be placed in the permanent
journal without
objection the majority committee on
education funding to which was referred
House Bill 739 FN act relative to excess
funds paid to municipalities for the use
of school districts having considered
the same report the same with the
following Amendment the recommendation
Bill ought to pass with Amendment sen
Walter spillsbury for the majority of
the
committee minority of the committee
having considered the same being unable
to agree with the majority Report with
the following resolution resolved that
is inexpedient to legislate Sally
fellows for the minority of the
committee for what reason does a member
rise for a motion St your motion I would
like uh to have 739 be laid on the
table that is a proper motion the motion
before us is to lay House Bill 739 on
the
table division has been requested
members take your
seats I know it e
the motion before us is to lay House
Bill 739 on the table this is a division
vote chair recognizes representative
cordelli for a parliamentary
inquiry thank you Mr Speaker Mr Speaker
if I know that this is is simply a
redistribution of money scheme and if I
know that the last time that this donor
Town scheme was introduced it led to a
division a bipartisan division across
the state and if I know that this will
simply pit neighbor against neighbor
once more would I now press the green
button chair recognize representative
spells for a parliamentary
inquiry thank you Mr
Speaker Mr Speaker if I know that HB 739
resolves a constitutional issue that is
been put in play by a superior court
decision and if I know that the
education funding committee has voted
for 739 OTP 17 to1
even though we know that it affects
different communities
differently and finally Mr Speaker if I
know that the decision up or down needs
to made be made today so that the bill
can move to finance and so that Finance
can determine how to use the $30 million
that it would raise would I now vote
against the table
motion motion before us is the table
House Bill 739 this is a division vote
if you're in favor you'll press the
green button if you're oppose you press
the red button voting stations are open
for 30 seconds
[Music]
all members present and an opportunity
to vote also will attend to stay to the
vote 50 voting a 223 voting a the motion
fails want any Amendment have the
amendment the motion the amendment is
0680 printed in house record 15 page 64
are you ready for the question on the
amendment all those in favor say I I
oppose nay the eyes the eyes have it the
amendment is adopted right now now now
we're on to autop pass with Amendment
and the chair recognizes representative
cordelli thank you Mr
Speaker this bill actually should be
titled the pitting against neighbor
bill because that is what this bill does
after after all it is a basic
redistribution of tax dollars from one
town to another from one taxpayer to
another the bill proposes to do with
taxpayer funds raised by the Statewide
education property tax or swept if the
town collects more then the state says
that they have to collect that is
referred to as excess swept even though
that term appears appears nowhere in
current
statute um this bill would require that
that excess amount that is over what the
state requires towns to collect be sent
to the state and have it redistributed
to other towns around the state maybe we
should expand that concept maybe we
should let Manchester Tax Bedford
taxpayers and if the amount of education
adequacy grant
increases the list of donor towns will
grow from the current
40 and why do these towns raise more
money than the state says that they have
to the Department of Revenue
Administration determines an equalized
property value for towns and uses that
to determine the amount owed by each
town to raise the required swept funds
and it is a uniform rate across the
state as required by our
constitution it happens that some towns
have some properties that have more
value than others maybe around the
lake and let's look at the two two of
the three towns that I represent because
they're a good
example uh considering there are 236
towns let's take a look at the
percentage of students qualifying for
free free and reduced lunch because
that's a commonly used measure of
poverty
Tuftonboro free and reduced percentage
is 26 a
half% wolf proo is
25.2% the state average is
145% as a measure of
poverty let's look at the 2023 median
income per
household for Wolf
bro it is
$8,300 for Tuftonboro is
$84,500
the state average is
$95,600
are my two towns wealthy clearly
not but let's take that those taxpayer
monies and distribute it to other towns
for those two towns currently this would
require $3
million to be sent from these towns to
the state to be
redistributed and what do you think is
going to happen to local property taxes
and the people who are struggling to
make ends meet we talk about fairness
does this sound fair
what do I tell Maryland a friend of mine
who lives in a old trailer in a trailer
park and has to rely on people to bring
her
groceries what am I going to tell her
when I have to say that some of her tax
dollars is going to people in Grafton
County or how about the families in town
for whom my church spends over $10,000 a
year to help them keep their heat on
during the winter what am I going to
tell
them please vote red to stop this excess
swept Caper and stop pitting neighbor
against neighbor and Mr Speaker I
request a roll call
vote chair recognize rep Senate
spillsbury
thank you Mr
Speaker love it or hate it the Statewide
education property taxx is current
law as current law it has to be
administered in a way that's
constitutional it looks an awful lot
like the local property tax to our
taxpayers but it is a state tax and so
it has to be apportioned with an equal
rate across the state when certain
communities are allowed to keep the
portion of the tax they collected
through swept that exceeds the amount
they're due from adequacy
Aid they can defray other costs in the
community and I and the committee
concurs with the judge that's decided
that's not constitutional and the
current law can't stand as it's
written so it is not the purpose to pit
communities against other communities I
think we have to be matter of fact and
recognize that when we impose any kind
of a tax we are not necessarily trying
to have the monies that have been
collected spent directly where they've
been collected or in proportion to the
distribution of collection look for
example at the meals and rooms tax the
meals and rooms tax is shared across the
communities regardless of which
communities have more
hotels more
restaurants more hospitals or whatever
draws people into the community we are
we are not trying to match up Community
by Community the amount collected and
the amount sent there that's the same
proposition here so if we're going to
collect part of our taxes on the real
estate through
swep if that's the wisdom of this body
then we need to make it constit tional
please support the motion of the
committee the motion before us is a
majority committee report of a passes
amended on House Bill 739 pres of Celli
has requested a roll call is that
sufficiently
seconded it is sufficiently
seconded this will be a roll call
vote members take your seats
okay that's
the motion before us majority commit a
report of a passes amend House Bill 739
this is a roll call vote chair
recognized representative McFarland for
a parliamentary
inquiry Mr Speaker if I know that
education funding in New Hampshire is
and should remain local and if I know
that forcing certain so-called donor
towns including two of the 10 towns in
my district Bridgewater and Hebron to
send their local education tax dollars
to the state will necessarily result in
higher property taxes for those
communities hurting Working Families and
seniors on fixed incomes in those towns
and if I know
that should the Supreme Court uphold the
conval decision the swept tax rate could
increase so as to fund the 80% higher
adequacy amount and increasing thereby
the number of donor towns in the state
by over three
times and if I know that despite claims
of fairness this bill merely
incentivizes those donor towns to spend
their otherwise excess funds on local Bo
doggles that they can label
educational ensuring that despite the
intent of the proponents of this bill no
real RIS redistribution of wealth would
actually
occur in the long term and that the bill
would ultimately raise education
representative this is a parliamentary
inquiry not a speech thank thank you Mr
Speaker I will wrap it up and if I know
that the bill would
therefore raise educational spending in
the donor towns and fail to provide
meaningful tax relief to other
communities and if I know that New
Hampshire voters have rejected state
taxes in favor of local control and this
would create division between towns
would I now press the red
button chair recogniz representative
spillsbury for a parliamentary
inquiry thank you Mr Speaker if I know
you don't have to agree with the judge
and all the rest of the conal and the
ran to see the constitutional problem
and if I know you've already heard me
twice tell you the reasons to support
this bill then would I now vote
Yes the motion before us is majority
committee report of Auto passes amended
and House Bill 739 it's a roll call vote
if you're in favor you'll press the
green button if you're oppos you'll
press the red button voting stations are
open for 30
seconds e
[Music]
all members present had an opportunity
to vote house will attend to stay to the
vote 246 voting a 128 voting a committee
report is
adopted and it's going to Ways and
Means for what reason does a member rise
Mr Speaker I move that the remarks on
House Bill 739 be put in the permanent
journal without objection
committee on education funding to which
was referred House Bill 773 FN an act
relative to Aid to school districts for
the cost of special education consider
the same report the same with the
following Amendment the recommendation
Bill all to pass for Amendment sen
Walter spillsbury for the committee the
amendment is
0714 printed in house record 15 page 66
are you ready for the question on the
amendment all those in favor say I
oppos n the eyes have it the amendment
is adopted the motion before us now is
ought to pass with Amendment are you
ready for the question all those in
favor say I I I suppose nay the eyes
have it and the committee report is
adopted it's going to Fin and it's going
to
finance majority of committee on
education policy and administration to
which was referred House Bill 667 FN an
act relative to health educ if ation and
requiring the viewing of certain videos
demonstrating gestational development
from embryo to fetus through Birth by
public school students and college or
university
students having considered the same
report the same with the following
Amendment the recommendation to Bill
ought to pass with Amendment
representative Glenn cardelli for the
majority of the
committee minority of the committee
having considered the same being in
agree with the majority Report with the
following resolution resolve it as inexp
to legislate Representative Steven
Woodcock from the minority of the
committee the amendment is
0615 H printed in house record 15 page
61 are you ready for the question on the
amendment all those in favor say I I
those oppose
nay eyes have it the amendment is
adopted the motion before us now is
ought to pass with Amendment the chair
recognizes representative woodcock
thank you Mr
Speaker HB
667 amends the current New Hampshire
educational Health curriculum to require
the viewing of fetal development in the
animated video and provide instruction
about
adoption currently the new New Hampshire
Department of Education provides the
standards and assessments for each
curriculum area and taught in public
schools including health
education and according to our current
RSA
189 the topics include physiology
hygiene Health interpersonal
relationships Wellness related to the
effects of alcohol and Other Drugs
prevention of sexual violence child
abuse HIV AIDS and sexually transmitted
diseases Additionally the New Hampshire
new doe 306 Health curriculum standards
identify by sexual behavior and
pregnancy prevention including
abstinence instruction in adoption is
not required it has nothing to do with
student health and wellness nor does it
prescribe any specific video handout
book or other reference
material doe of New Hampshire has an
overreaching philosophy of human
sexuality education and I quote it from
the state growth and development are are
Dynamic nurturing processes with
physical mental emotional and social
aspects personal and family
relationships and influences are Central
to the attitudes and decisions about
sexual
behavior unprotected sex can lead to
unattended pregnancies and sexually
transmitted diseases STDs including HIV
and AIDS abstinence is the most
effective method of preventing pregnancy
and STDs different methods of
contraception have varying defectiveness
in preventing pregnancy and fcds that is
the overarching principle from the state
of New Hampshire curriculum in the
website nowhere nowhere in any of the
state's human sexuality guidelines
recommendations topics to be covered or
assessments does the state identify a
specific text video animation or method
of
assessment
why because that's lift up to each each
local community and their school board
the School's application of the human
sexuality instruction is no different
than any other academic subject the
state sets the guidelines and the local
community and School Board determine the
specific instruction of the curriculum
area so how many sitting in this room
have ever seen a bill come forward to
this floor to this floor requiring which
Masterpiece should be read in
English or which Shakespeare experi work
should be included as a part of the high
school curriculum what about Rec
required the reading of our fellow New
England is the road not taken while
living in New Hampshire I think at least
John Greenley footy is snowbound should
be
required my point is this we the members
of this legislature should not be
dictating the specific pieces of local
Community School curriculum let me
provide a little bit of context and
background for my comments today in full
disclosure you need to know that I
taught High School human sexuality
portion of the high curriculum for four
years in the school system where I was
department chair the faculty had the
option to opt out and they all did
nobody wanted to teach it so that that
portion of the health curriculum fell to
the apartment chair which was me I was
fortunate to have had the academic
training evidence-based information and
the skill to dialogue about this very
difficult area with our students
sexuality education does not have to be
one-sided dirty vague gory or
stimulating nor nor should it provide
the personal philosophy of the teacher
in essence it's a pretty simple
biologically based datadriven subject
enhanced with discussion about safety
transmitted diseases personal
responsibility as well as the
sensitivity of of the teacher to the
realities of dating sexual activity at
the high school level and current data
on sexual violence and Trauma involving
high school students honestly today's
Bill 667 is the issue but fundamentally
not because of local control but rather
because individuals are attempting to
interject their personal positions of
pro-life or pro-choice through the
school curriculum requirements let me be
clear how high school students are
required to take health education for
the basically one short course over four
years half a year sexuality education is
just one brief portion of it so please
allow local school boards who have hired
professionally trained instructors those
that understand the issues of High
School population to do the teaching and
selection of materials that best for
their Community it's not our place doe
has provided the guidance let your town
School Board do the job your local
people voted for them to do and let us
do our job please vote no push the red
button so an itl motion can be brought
forward thank you Mr Speaker and I
request a division vote chair recognize
rep sener
cordelli thank you Mr
Speaker I almost thought that the uh
previous speaker was uh giving part of
my speech um this amended bill is very
simple and updates the current RSA on
health
education it starts by saying that
curriculum should be age appropriate and
medically accurate how controversial is
that the amendment then repeats what is
in our state health standards and
Department of Education administrative
rules spe specifically calling for
abstinence and healthy relationships
that's in the amended
okay um it does mention
adoption as someone who was adopted and
who picked out my sister from an
orphanage um abortion is important to me
and I'll point out that if you do a
search on the CDC website for abortion
it says see also
adoption the amended Bill includes that
sexuality education include growth and
development of vital organs in a
developing
baby isn't that somewhat
important uh it does not I repeat does
not require any specific video to be
shown I was talking to a former
presidential candidate u a couple of
weeks ago who was a friend and he
mentioned that he just had a grandson
born at 23 3 weeks old weighing one
pound what is the status of the baby's
organs vital organs at 23 weeks wouldn't
that be interesting to look at and when
does this baby start moving around the
womb or maybe I could just ask one of
the moms in the room um the opponents of
this bill uh raised the objection about
local control and that curriculum is a
local responsibility
but as the previous speaker said the
current statute says the school board
shall ensure that health education
physical education include exercise
Wellness
Etc it says the curriculum
shall this RSA is about specifying what
should be taught in school and is a
reasonable and necessary provision and
Common Sense please support the
committee majority and press the green
button Mr
Speaker for what reason do a member rise
to make a motion State your motion I
move that we lay HB 667 upon the table
that is a proper
motion motion before us is to Table Six
667 a division has been requested
members take your seats
person
C
speak e
the motion before us is the lady House
Bill 666 667 on the table this is a
division vote chair recognized
representative Jama for a parliamentary
inquiry thank you Mr Speaker if I know
that current standards in this area
suffice and if I know that we have a
very long afternoon of work that we
still have to get to but I press the
green button to lay hb6 67 on the table
thank you chair recognize representer
cordelli for a parliamentary inquiry
thank you if I agree that we have a Long
Afternoon ahead of us but if I also know
that we've already heard the arguments
on this bill and all we have to do is
vote on it would I press the red button
so we can get on with
it the motion before us is to lay House
Bill
6767 on the table this is a division
vote if you're in favor you'll press the
green button if you're opposed you'll
press the red button voting stations are
open for 30 seconds
[Music]
represent
bman all members present had an
opportunity to vote how attend to state
of the vote
180 voting aay 188 voting aay the motion
fails now we're back to the original
motion of ought to pass as
amended this is a division right are you
ready for the
question all those in FA all those in
favor say I
those oppos
[Applause]
nay a
Dei a division was called before I put
the hammer
down we I didn't hear
it this will be a division vote for
clarification purposes
we're not we're not doing
Pi the motion before us is ought to pass
as amended if you're in favor you'll
press the green button if you oppose you
press the red button voting stations are
open for 30 seconds
[Music]
represent power and
McDonald represent McDonald
well members presid had an opportunity
to vote also attend to stay to the
vote 189 v e day 1880 voting a committee
report is
adopted and it is going to finance
ch e
[Music]
the majority of the committee on
Election law to which was referred House
Bill 365 FN an act relative to proof of
United States citizenship for Indigent
voters having considered the same report
the same with the recommendation that
the bill a to ask representative Ross
Barry for the majority of the committee
the minority of the committee having
considered the same and being unable to
agree with the majority Report with the
following resolution resolved that it is
inexpedient to legislate representative
Connie Lane for the minority of the
committee representative Lane's
recognized speak against the committee
report thank you Mr
Speaker and good afternoon we're up to
eel um I I suspect um this well let me
back up this bill offers the use of
databases by clerks and the Secretary of
State to provide the citizenship
documents that are now required for you
to register to vote it also provides
assistance to Indigent registrants
willing to sign an
affidavit that they are
Indigent so I suspect that most of you
on the speaker's right hand side are
about to tune me out but I ask that you
at least give me the courtesy of
listening to why I urge you to vote
against this bill because it is not
ready to use the cliche it is not ready
for prime prime time yes I disagree with
the policy but I also disagree that we
should pass a bill with this many
flaws first the majority of the election
law committee voted to pass this bill
even though no one spoke in support of
the
bill neither sponsor nor anyone on their
behalf explained to the committee why
this bill is necessary or if the
solutions offered in the bill are
feasible or if they even exist the
Secretary of State testified that he
knows of no federal database or another
State's database that is available to
his office or to a clerk's office to
help New Hampshire citizens obtain
evidence of
citizenship he does however have access
to the New Hampshire division of Vital
Records so he can obtain a birth
certificate for those who are born or
were born in New Hampshire so
consequently this bill will at most help
maybe one onethird of those registered
voters who were born in New Hampshire so
what about the rest of the two-thirds of
us that were not born in New Hampshire
what does this bill give us nothing it
does not offer you anything you have to
have been born in New Hampshire and not
have changed your name so that
eliminates most
women in order to have in order for this
bill to work for you and if you are one
of those lucky oneir that was born in
the granite state and you can't afford
to pay for the birth certificate this
bill will help you but it will only help
you if you sign a sworn affidavit that
you are
Indigent again that term is not even
defined in the bill and the Secretary of
State acknowledged that he did not know
how that would be defined and how that
would work he also was not sure how the
voucher system that was set up to repay
the towns and cities envisioned by the
bill will work so leaving Indigent
undefined in the bill is a glaring
Omission that makes the bill
unworkable all of this aside it's
offensive that we are asking New
Hampshire citizens to prove that they
are so poor that they cannot exercise
their most important right the right to
vote stop for a minute and think how
demeaning and humiliating it would be
for you to stand in front of your local
Clerk and admit that you're so poor that
you need to get money a voucher to get a
copy of your birth certificate so that
you can go
vote why would we do that to anyone we
have the copies of those cert those
birth certificates in the government
database the taxpayers have already paid
for them why don't we just offer them to
anybody who walks in and says I was born
in New Hampshire I'd like to have a a
copy of my birth certificate and give it
to them so that way they have it in an
easy way now that only solves it for
that one-third but at least those
onethird would be able to
vote I have one more reason for you not
to vote for the bill the Secretary of
State in his testimony said that it was
not just Indigent people who needed help
help with obtaining citizen Citizenship
documentation and ask that those people
be considered as well when the bill was
discussed in the
committee well there was no such
discussion no response was made by the
sponsors to amend the deficiencies
identified in the public hearing so
without addressing these deficiencies
the bill is most likely
unconstitutional and violate the federal
and state ADA
requirements we already have one lawsuit
challenging last year's HB
1569 and this one will just be rolled
into that lawsuit New Hampshire spent $3
million on the sv3 lawsuit and it will
probably spend at least that much
defending this bill and HB
1569 I know know that I do not look
forward to trying to explain to my
constituents that we are spending $3
million on attorneys fees rather than
lowering their property taxes or
supporting their schools to summarize
this bill is not ready to be passed for
six reasons there's no public hearing
testimony supporting the bill even from
the sponsors or others supporting the
bill the online support was
57 40
472 people opposed it I do not think
that I have ever voted for a bill in
this chamber where there was no
supporting testimony provided by the
sponsors of a bill or other speaking on
their behalf the databases offered as
Solutions in this bill do not exist for
over 2third of New Hampshire voters the
database solution offered in this bill
was actually rejected by us last
year the bill insults and demeans New
Hampshire voters who are unfortunate
enough to be considered Indigent once we
decide what that means since New
Hampshire birth certificates are already
available at the at the uh Secretary of
State's office through their um archives
just provide them to anybody who wants
to register and that way we can avoid
the stigmat of having people declaring
themselves
Indigent the bill does not define two
critical terms in that make that are
needed to make it work one is reasonable
reasonable evidence and the other is
Indigent without these definitions the
bill is seriously
flawed the bill does not address the
comments raised by the Secretary of
State about who else needs help with
documentation or other comments raised
in the public testimony this leaves the
bill right for
litigation so even if I agreed with the
policy behind this bill I would not vote
for it for all the reasons that I've
explained to you the Bill's flawed if
you were going to pass a bill make sure
that it can withstand litigation and
make sure that it offers real solutions
this bill does nether I ask that you
please vote against the OTP motion and I
ask for division vote
representative Barry's recognized to
speak in support of the committee report
uh thank you and I I believe I'm one of
the sponsors so I guess to address the
um minorities concerns uh here I am
testifying about why we should pass this
um when we when we passed our historic
uh election law Bill last year where we
said no in New Hampshire you're going to
prove how old you are where you live who
you are and that you're a US citizen we
knew that we were going to have to
follow it up the minority made the
complaint at the time that hey people
aren't going to be able to get these
citizenship documents they're not going
to be able to afford them here you go
here's your
solution this bill allows people who
declare themselves to be inent to get
the documents that we say they need to
vote so if you want more people to vote
this is it I ask that the body vote
green questions on the majority
committee report about to pass and House
Bill 365 division votes been requested
it'll be a division vote members take
your
seats e
the questions on the majority committee
report have about to pass and House Bill
365 and this is a division vote
representative Lane is recognized for a
parliamentary
inquiry thank you Mr Speaker if I know
there was no testimony supporting the
bill even from the sponsors and if I
know the databases offered as Solutions
in this bill do not exist for over
2third of New Hampshire voters so in
other words it's an illus an illusory
solution the New Hampshire birth
certificates are available to the SOS so
providing them to all New Hampshire
residents we could avoid the stigma and
not have to humiliate people and try and
learn how to define Indigent and if I
know the bill does not find Define two
critical terms and if I know the fact
that the bill does not address the
comments that were raised by the
Secretary of State and others are
addressed in the bill then I would push
the red press push whatever you want to
call it the red button to oppose the OTP
motion so that another motion can be
made thank you representative Bar's
recognized for parliamentary
inquiry thank you Mr Speaker uh Mr
Speaker if I know that this bill will
make it easier for people to vote while
protecting our much needed proof of
citizenship requirement when I now press
the green button
the questions on the majority committee
report of about to pass and House Bill
365 this is a division vote if you're in
favor press the green button oppose
press the red voting stations are open
for 30 seconds
[Music]
represent
B have all members present had an
opportunity to vote the house will
attend of the state of the vote to 100
in the affirmative 169 and the negative
the report is
adopted House Bill 365 is referred to
the committee on
finance the majority of the committee on
Election law to which was referred House
Bill 521 FN an act authorizing online
voter registration having considered the
same report the same with the following
resolution resolved that it is
inexpedient to legislate representative
James gzowski for the majority of the
committee the minority of the committee
having considered the same and being
unable to agree with the majority Report
with the recommendation that the bill
ought to pass representative Connie Lane
for the minority of the committee
representative Mir has recognized to
speak against the committee report
Mr
Speaker this bill would allow citizens
of New Hampshire to register to vote
online that's something
that every citizen under 40 expects to
be able to do because they do everything
online the bill would allow citizens to
fill out a voter registration form and
to submit necessary
documentation using an online
portal that documentation and those
forms will be verified by clerks just as
they are now the only acceptable
identification for online registrant
would be a New Hampshire issued driver's
license or non-d drivers's
ID this would make registering to vote
secure
efficient and easy 42 states in the
United States of America 42 States
currently allow citizens to register to
vote
online among those 42 are a great number
of what are called red States and blue
states to be more specific a red state
is one where the Republican party has a
trifecta control a majority in the house
the state senate and controls the
governorship a blue state where the
Democrats control all three things there
are 12 Democratic Trifecta states that
use that allow citizens to register to
vote online there are 15 Republican
Trifecta
states that allow citizens to register
to vote online so this is not the pet
idea of one party this is not an idea
that benefits one party at the expense
of another this is just a good
idea the New Hampshire Secretary of
State said implementing implementation
of a voter portal would not change C the
current process of how a voter registers
to vote the Secretary of State
continued to say that online voter
registration quote is
streamlined and will improve the process
will cut down the time at the polling
place and improved data collection by
the supervisors of the
checklist this bill passed this body
last year it made sense then it makes
sense now it makes sense in blue States
it makes sense in red States it just
makes sense so I beg my colleagues to
vote against this itail motion thank you
Mr
Speaker representative Barry's
recognized speak in support of the
committee report thank you Mr Speaker uh
Mr Speaker uh this is online voter
registration uh what could go wrong and
uh the website it cost $2.5 million so
no thank you uh this Tri this trifecto
Republican state will be voting no
today the questions on the majority
committee report of inexpedient to
legislate and a division's been
requested who requested the roll
call is that sufficiently
seconded it is sufficiently seconded
this will be a roll call vote members
take your seats
I mean
questions on the majority committee
report of inexpedient to legislate on
House Bill
521 repr representative Lan's recognized
for a parliamentary
inquiry thank you Mr Speaker if I know
that this bill streamlines our
registration process making it easier
for people to register which is a good
thing and if I know the supervisor of
the checklist will still make the
decision of whether to register the
online applicant and if I know that 42
states have online Reg registration
without security concerns and if I know
that this house and the Chamber on the
other side of the wall both passed
online registration last year but we
could not agree at the last minute on
the details then would I press the red
button to oppose the it itl motion so a
different motion can be made thank you
and we ask for a division vote please
representative Barry's recognized for
parliamentary inquiry
uh thank you Mr Speaker Mr Speaker if I
know that this is online voter
registration and what could go wrong and
Mr Speaker if I know this is a $2.5
million website would I now press the
red button to defeat this the green
button the green button to defeat this
legislation green green green Green
which why we
ask the questions on the majority
committee report have been expedient to
legislate on 521 and this is a roll call
vote if you're in favor press the green
button opposed press the red voting
stations are open for 30 seconds
muray Murray
[Music]
repres
wood have all members present and an
opportunity to vote the house will
attend of the state of the vote
202 in the affirmative 169 and negative
the Motions
adopted before I read the next bill in
every session day somebody will grab me
in the hall and say how late are we
going to go today and my answer is
always the same I don't know how long
you going to
talk you ultimately have control over
that and I'm only bringing it up cuz
that is a a big pile of bills to be
looking at at 3:00 in the afternoon so
you can help your colleagues out if you
can try to find a way to encourage
brevity for the rest of the day but
that's that's a lot of
bills chair recogniz as a clerk thank
you Mr Speaker I have a letter uh dated
today and from the committee of from the
chair of the committee on finance uh Mr
Speaker I hereby wave the second
committee referral pursuing to house
rule 47f of house Bill 667 and House
Bill
739 the majority of the committee on
Election laot which is referred as Bill
714 FN an acts creating a single primary
ballot having considered the same report
the same with the following resolution
resolved that it is inexpedient to
legislate representative Clayton wood
for the majority of the committee the
minority of the committee having
considered the same and being unable to
agree with the majority Report with the
recommendation that the bill ought to
pass representative Russell Mirad for
the minority of the
committee representative Mir has
recognized to for what reason does a
member rise uh yes Mr Speaker to make a
motion State your motion I'd like to
move to table House Bill 714
representative Barry moves to lay House
Bill 714 on the table are you ready for
the question all those in favor say
I all those oppose nay no all right
then a vant effort House Bill 714s laid
on the table
that's how you do
it the majority of the committee on
executive departments and administration
to which was referred House Bill 52 an
act relative to legal holidays having
considered the same report the same with
the recommendation that the bill ought
to pass representative Heath Howard for
the majority of the committee the
minority of the committee having
considered the same and being unable to
agree with the majority Report with the
recommendation that it is inexpedient to
legislate representative Erica Leon for
the minority of the
committee representative Barry's
recognized to speak against the
committee report
representative
Barry going
once going
twice representative Leon will'll pinch
it thank you Mr Speaker at first look
this bill seems like a great idea who
doesn't want a holiday for
elections the only problem is we are
giving a state holiday to all state
employees at the local level the state
level School level except for essential
employees I've spoken with Clerks of
cities who are paying
overtime plus extra time for the extra
hours worked for people in their cities
when they are working in the election s
this is a significant cost to local
taxpayers also that people can have the
day off to drive greater
turnout the question is how much will
this drive turnout we saw just this week
that turnout at local elections is quite
low but those who are involved in the
local government process are those who
do show up already how many people are
going to see going to see a real
difference other than in their property
tax bill for some extra hours the fact
that we have a holiday for CH for the
primaries for generals general election
presidential um primary and for the
general election this is going to be
expensive this isn't really going to
help much out and this is really not a
good idea because we need to make sure
that people are doing their jobs we're
not giving extra holidays and New
Hampshire does a great job getting out
the vote so let's vote against the ought
to pass motion and press the red button
representative Howard's recognized to
speak for the committee
report thank you Mr Speaker there are 12
state holidays listed in
rsas non-essential State offices close
on all of those days except one election
day please tell me why we have a day to
celebrate the birth of our Republic
Independence Day a day to celebrate
those who fought to protect our Republic
Memorial Day or Veterans Day those a day
to honor those who have died for our
Republic Memorial Day a day to celebrate
the birthday of notable presidents who
served our Republic President's Day and
even a day to honor the discovery of the
continent that would become our home the
home of our Republic Columbus Day but
not a day to allow our citizens to
actually participate in the
Republic the business of voting which
makes a republic a republic I have heard
complaints that well maybe having a
holiday is too would cost too much but
since hourly employees will not even be
working that day and all salary
employees won't be getting paid more at
all uh at most we will be losing a
little productivity on that day a day
that isn't very productive anyway since
half of the employees come in late take
long lunches or even leave early to go
vote the cost is negligible
in fact the bill didn't even have a
fiscal note I would say it's basically
the cost of a snow day except since guns
are allowed at polling places and most
polling places are schools uh it turns
out the biggest closure that happens on
a state holiday the schools are already
closing so this is a negligible cost or
perhaps even a savings in fact uh most
PE if most people get the day off they
no longer need child care uh to take
care of their kids who are already
having the day off and instead can bring
their kids to the polls and teach them
about their civic duty I also heard
people making the argument that this
treats private employees and public
employees different of course we do
nowhere in law do we tell businesses
that they have to close if you work at a
gas station and your boss says that you
have to work on Christmas you work on
Christmas Christmas I remember about 5
years ago when we forcibly closed
businesses it wasn't good we don't close
private businesses for any of our
holidays and so this bill does not close
private businesses either it does allow
up for three hours of unpaid time off uh
for private employees to who work during
polling hours and request to go vote
because everyone should should have a
chance to have their voice heard in our
Republic our Founders intended for us to
have the opportunity to vote they said
it on a Tuesday specifically because
they deemed that day to be the most
accessible to the people who at the time
were a farming society and went to
church on
Sundays Tuesdays don't work for us
anymore and while we can't change
federal law we can give Granite Staters
the best chance to go and vote in our
state I imagine a state that looks at
this date on their calendar and starts
thinking about the issues and where they
stand and researching candidates plans
planning barbecues and debates and
parties and really truly celebrate the
public engagement in right to vote I
never met a citizen uh of this State
against a holiday but this holiday is a
no-brainer election day is integral to
our Republic everyone should embrace the
ility to vote and if we have any holiday
as any state holiday as a holiday that
we get off it should be this one thank
you does a member yield for a
question no I do
not questions on the majority committee
report about to pass on House Bill 52 in
a division been requested this will be a
division vote members take your
seats for
clear
questions on the majority committee
report about to pass on House Bill 52
representative Lon is recognized for
parliamentary
inquiry thank you Mr Speaker if I know
that I love holidays but if I know that
this bill is a solution in search of a
problem would I then press the red
button representative wheelers
recognized for parliamentary
inquiry Mr Speaker would you believe
that our Republic is worth the cost of a
single snow day every two years so that
all the people in our state could come
out to vote and Mr Speaker would you
believe that the president of the United
States has come out and signaled support
for making Election Day a holiday
because it secures our elections and Mr
Speaker would you believe that I enjoy
giving a parliamentary inquiry even
though I was told to do it one bill
beforehand then would I then vote with
the committee to pass this legislation
and move forward thank you Mr
Speaker the questions on the majority
committee report about to pass an House
Bill
52 this is a division vote if you're in
favor press the green button opposed
press the red voting stations are open
for 30 seconds
[Music]
have all members present had an
opportunity to vote the house will
attended the state of the vote
166 in the affirmative 205 and the
negative the motion fails representative
Leon moves in expedient to legislate on
House Bill 52 you ready for the question
all those in favor say
I all those opposed
nay the eyes have it 205 to 166 and the
motion's adopted
the majority of the committee on
executive departments and administration
which is referred as Bill 536 FN an act
relative to a cost of living adjustment
in the state retirement system having
considered the same report the same with
the recommendation that the bill ought
to pass representative Jackie groa for
the majority of the committee the
minority of the committee having
considered the same and being unable to
agree with the minor majority Report
with the following resolution resolved
that is inexpedient to legislate
representative Erica L for the minority
of the
committee representative SL is
recognized to speak against the
committee
report for what reason does the member
rise uh for a motion sir State your
motion uh move to lay 536 on the table
representative Osborne moves slos Bill
536 on the table are you ready for the
question division a division's been
requested or a roll call who requested
the roll
call who
nobody who requested the roll call
Granger request the roll call is that
sufficiently
seconded doesn't look like it this will
be a division vote members take your
seats
this is a division vote I see people in
the an room not
moving now if they don't move soon they
don't get to Comm
in the motion is to lay house bill 530
six on the table representative lons
recognized for a parliamentary
inquiry thank you Mr Speaker if I know
that this bill would give a $750 credit
they would go on basically a credit card
on Beyond people's property tax bills
for 20 years and if I know that that
means that the right bill for this right
thing for this bill is to lay it on the
table would I then press the green
button representative Gro is recognized
for parliamentary inquiry thank you Mr
Speaker Mr Speaker if I know that we
don't know what the cost of this because
it hasn't reached finance and that this
is simply a policy decision and we are
deciding to send it to finance where it
belongs would I vote no on the tabling
motion thank
you the questions ready to lay House
Bill 536 on the table it's a division
vote if you're in favor press the green
button oppos press the red voting
stations are open for 30 seconds
[Music]
have all members present and an
opportunity to vote
the house will attend to the state of
the vote 185 in the affirmative 177 in
the negative the motion is
adopted Representatives saitech mahagan
Dennis Manion Grant and Harrington
declared conflicts of interest and
recused themselves from the vote
the majority of the committee on
executive departments and administration
to which was referred House Bill 570 FN
an act relative to membership of the
prescription drug affordability board
and the definition of public payor for
purposes of board Administration having
considered the same report the same with
the following amendments and the
recommendation that the bill ought to
pass with Amendment representative Eric
Lon for the majority of the committee
the minority of the committee having
considered the same and being unable to
agree with the majority Report with the
following resolution resolved that it is
inexpedient to legislate representative
Jackie groa from the minority of the
committee the amendment is
01908 printed in house record 15 on page
48 questions on the adoption of the
amendment for what reason does a member
[Music]
rise to make a motion Mr Speaker State
your motion I'd like to lay House Bill
570 on the table representative groa
moves to lay House Bill 570 on the table
and I ask for a division vote this will
be a division vote members take your
seats who was
that representative Osborne request a
roll call is that sufficiently seconded
for sure this will be a roll call vote
members keep taking your seats
C
we
good question is whether lay House Bill
570 on the
table represent Woods is recognized for
parliamentary inquiry
thank you Mr
Speaker Mr
Speaker if I know that for the past
several years prescription drugs have
continued to become more unaffordable
while Pharmacy benefit managers pbms
sustain healthy
profits if I know the prescription drug
affordability board board's 2024 annual
report was written to educate buyers of
prescription drugs on how the
prescription drug Market is is genuinely
not a free market if I know the board
identified over $6 million in potential
Savings in the 2024 annual
report if I know the board uh is
currently reviewing in Connecticut a
prescription drug discount card which
does not incur any cost to the state and
which has shown over $200 savings on
some prescriptions and has saved
citizens of Connecticut over $1.2
million in 12 months and finally if I
know the origin of the current House
Bill one uh 117 to bring greater
competition to the biosimilars to lower
costs was a presentation to the
prescription drug affordability board
and the and that this board is critical
to finding more such solutions would I
then now vote to support the motion to
table HB 570 by pushing that glowing
green uh growing Spring Light spring
like green
button representative Edwards is
recognized for parliamentary inquiry uh
thank you Mr Speaker if if I knew that
this vote was really the first Salvo in
a very long protracted budget debate
that's going to be coming up in four
short weeks if I knew that that the
governor had over $500 million of
Revenue that the house that the house
does not have to work with if I knew
that we needed to have heavy
prioritization on activities that do not
provide a rate of a return on our
investment would I then vote red so that
we don't table this bill and have a full
debate on the underlying bill so that we
can do the fiscally responsible thing in
this situation and and get to the
underlying uh Amendment vote
R the questions where to lay House Bill
570 on the table that's roll call vote
if you're in favor press the green
button oppos press the red voting
stations are open for 30 seconds
[Music]
have all members present and an
opportunity to vote the house of
attendant the state of the
vote 167 in the affirmative 207 motion
fails we are back to the amendment
01908 printed anounced record 14 on page
48 you ready for the question all those
in favor say
I all those oppos
nay the eyes have it and the Amendments
adopted now honor the main motion of a
to pass as amended representative Gro
has recognized speak against the
committee
report I'm sorry Mr Speaker I was
distracted so am I speaking you're
you're inviting me to the well to speak
yes do you recognize to speak against
the committee report yes thank you yep
so the bill as amended repeals the
performance drug the per performance
drug I wish I could have one right now
the prescripture drug affordability
board um and I think that this needs to
be considered and have a bigger
conversation it's not something that you
should just easily Fritter away and uh
eliminate and uh so I hope that you'll
vote against the autop pass motion thank
you
representative Edwards is recognized to
speak for the committee report uh thank
you Mr Speaker as I mentioned a moment
ago uh this is really the uh the opening
test case and how we're going to be
handling the budget in uh this coming
four weeks uh we have an example of uh
of a um a board that's been in effect
for four years uh it's published four
reports there's not a single actionable
thing that they've said in these annual
reports for the four years that
justifies the money that we've been
putting in them they have come up with
some suggestions that have not been
coordinated and I've spent the last five
months working with the chair of the
board to turn what may be really good
ideas into actionable business cases and
my offer has not been taken up so I'm
left to believe that we don't have any
actionable business business case to
justify the money that we're spending on
the prescription drug affordability
board this has been a 4-year effort it's
unfortunate because I love the concept
of the board I'm a board member um but I
I I'm looking at Glen Cliffe New
Hampshire hospital SDC the vet home DD
nursing homes and like I said we are
$500 million short in revenue from the
governor if we can't cut a small little
program like this that is producing
nothing yet after four years we we
cannot get to where we need to be to
close out this budget so I'm going to
ask you to vote green and uh pass this
bill as
amended questions on the majority
committee report of ought to pass as
amended on House Bill
570 division been requested wed members
take your seats
the questions on the majority committee
report about to pass Amendment on House
Bill
570 representative Gro is recognized for
parliamentary
increase hi kki is recognized for a
inquiry thank you Mr
Speaker if I know that the PAB has a
budget line item of
$250,000 a year and that we heard
yesterday in the finance committee that
there's potential Savings of well over
$6 million and more coming if we just
let them follow through with what
they're working
on and if I know that the high cost of
prescription drugs is the number one
issue for many of our senior citizens
who've reached out to us this week would
I press the red button to vote down the
ought to pass
motion representative Carol Maguire is
recognized for parliamentary
inquiry thank you Mr Speaker
if I know that this well-intentioned
program has spent a modest amount of
money and produced absolutely nothing if
I know that this commission
has been identified by our commission on
redundancy as producing only data that
is redundant to other data produced by
other departments and if I know that
we're trying to eliminate that and if I
know that we will continue to spend
money to produce nothing if we do not
kill this bill we do not pass this bill
please press the green
button the questions of the majority
committee report of about to pass is
amended on House Bill 570 as a division
vote if you're in favor press the green
button oppos press the red voting
stations are open for 30 seconds
[Music]
of all members present had an
opportunity to vote house will attended
the state of the vote j five on the
affirmative 168 in the negative the
report is
adopted the chair recognizes a clerk
Finance um House Bill 570 is referred to
the committee on finance now the chair
recognizes the clerk thank you Mr
Speaker Mr Speaker the chairman of
Finance was overe exuberant in his
waiver of a second committee uh bill
that was not sent to him however um
House Bill 739 which was sent to the
committee on Ways and Means is hereby
waved uh pursu to house rule 4 47f as is
House Bill
499 the committee on executive
departments and administration which
referred House Bill 581 FN establishing
a state retirement plan group for new
state employee members of the retirement
system comes to us without
recommendation representative Dan
Maguire moves out to pass and offers
Amendment 0502 H for what reason does a
member
rise uh thank you Mr Speaker uh knowing
that um this has no future in finance I
move to lay HB 581 on the table
representative Osborne moves to lay
house bill 581 on the table you ready
for the question all those in favor say
I I all those oppose nay all right then
House Bill 581 is laid on the
table the majority of the committee on
executive departments and administration
which is referred as Bill 637 FN an act
relative to the reduction and the
calculation of State retirement
annuities at age 65 for group one
retirement system members having
considered the same report the same with
the following resolution resolved that
it is inexpedient to legislate
representative ericon for the majority
of the committee the minority of the
committee having considered the same
being unable to agree with the majority
Report with the recommendation that the
bill ought to pass representative Heath
Howard for the minority of the
committee for what reason does a member
rise I make a motion to table this bill
motion is to table House Bill
637 are you ready for the
question that's so this will be a
division vote members take your
seats you the p
questions whether to lay House Bill 637
on the table and representative Lyon's
recognized for a parliamentary
inquiry thank you Mr Speaker if I know
this bill came to us with the intention
of fixing an oversight in a previous
bill that started in the other chamber
and then went into the budget and was
approved by this body but if I know in
the first time that was heard in January
and then when it was heard in a second
committee and then when it was added to
the budget it was made very clear that
anybody who retired before that budget
went into effect would not get the extra
bump up in retirement pay uh based upon
the Social Security full retirement age
and if therefore I know that this was a
conscious Choice uh when this happened
and while unfortunate we don't even know
the financial implications of how large
this cost would be and it is not funded
would I then press the green button to
put this on the
table representative Howard's recognized
for parliamentary inquiry thank you Mr
Speaker if I know that 2,700 employees
were left out during last B anum's
change and if I know that in 1988 the
retirement system was unlined from
Social Security and if I know that these
retirees will see a reduction in how
much they receive for two years from age
65 to when they receive social security
at age 67 then I would press the red
button so that we can discuss this bill
further thank
you the question is whether way House
Bill 6 37 on the table and this is a
division vote if you're in favor press
the green button oppos press the red
voting stations are open for 30 seconds
[Music]
have all members present had an
opportunity to vote the house will
attend of the state of the
vote 229 in the affirmative 136 in a
negative 637 is laid on the
table the committee on Health Human
Services and elderly Affairs to which is
referred House Bill 645 FN an act
relative to data collection and
Reporting requirements of the
prescription drug affordability board
having considered the same report the
same with the following Amendment and
the recommendation that the bill ought
to pass with Amendment representative
Jim kofalt for the committee for what
reason does a member rise uh Mr Speaker
having already passed HB 570 leaving HB
645 unnecessary a move to lay HB 645 on
the table representative Osborne moves
to lay House Bill 645 on the table you
ready for the question all those in
favor say
I all those oppose nay
no yeah
pretty sure the eyes have it and 637
6:45 is laid on
this committee on housing which is
referred House Bill 572 FN an act
establishing the partners and housing
program a low interest loan and grant
program under the housing Champions fund
to assist municipalities counties and
developers and building Workforce
housing having considered the same
report the same with the following
Amendment and the recommendation that
the bill ought to pass with Amendment
representative David pagee for the
committee the amendment is
0560 printed an Ask record 15 on pages
48 to 50 questions on the adoption of
the amendment you ready for the question
all those in favor say I I all those
pose
nay guys have it and the Amendments
adopted questions now is on the main
motion of ought to pass with Amendment
you ready for the question all those in
favor say I I all those oos n
the eyes have it and the report is
adopted
to House Bill 572 is referred to the
committee on finance
the majority of the committee on
Judiciary to which was referred House
Bill 611 FN an act abolishing
recruitment procedures regarding
appointed councel for Indigent criminal
defendants having considered the same
report the same with the following
Amendment and the recommendation that
the bill ought to pass with Amendment
Representative Bob Lynn for the majority
of the committee the minority of the
committee having considered the same and
being unable to agree with the majority
Report with the following Amendment and
the recommendation that the bill ought
to pass with Amendment represent Paul
bur for the minority of the
committee the majority amendment is
06388 printed anoun record 15 on pages
56 to
57 representative bur is recognized to
speak against the amendment
thank you Mr
Speaker I suppose I could start with a a
moment of appreciation from the
gentleman from Auburn who spoke
to uh the need to cut programs that uh
don't
financially um recommend themselves we
have a program that seeks to recoup
money from poor people who are assigned
a lawyer
in criminal court because they cannot
afford to hire one and who have been
found guilty and from parents of
children who have been found
delinquent their inability to pay is
checked by a judge in each
case so the state creates an office of
Cost Containment fills it up with some
government
employees whose job it
is to try to collect money from people
who have no m
money needless to say it's an
unsuccessful program trying to get money
from folks who do not have it but might
someday like win a lottery or collect an
inheritance good for the government
employees pretty easy job not so good
for the
taxpayers so HB 611 was filed to Simply
end this failure of a
program the the response is the
amendment under
consideration to Double Down by making
the program
larger to now
additionally Bild graned Staters who
have been found
innocent and the parents of children who
have been cleared of
wrongdoing of course if you're going to
go over if you're going to go after more
people you're going to have to hire more
government
employees buy more computers and stamps
or however they fill their days and
Common Sense will tell you they will
just lose more
money it's like a guy who sells widgets
for a loss but thinks he will make it up
in
volume kind of doesn't work that
way but this is the premise behind the
amendment and all it will accomplish is
grow the state with hiring more and more
government employees to try to get blood
from a stone Now by Dunning totally
innocent granted Staters week after week
month after month year after year in the
hope that somebody wins the lottery so
he can pay the cost of his public
defender a cost that was only incurred
because the state falsely accused him of
a
crime the current fiscal
projections for fiscal
26 without this amendment
even
$320,000 in
revenue and the cost to pay for the
government employees and their desks and
their stamps and computers would be
371,000 with costs going up to
383,000 in fiscal
2027 so bring in
320,000 spend 371 or 383,000 to try to
collect it only one state out of 50 has
a program that's anything like this
South which is South Dakota and it's
done by local jurisdictions in South
Dakota and we all know there's no people
in South
Dakota 50 states do not do what this
amendment suggests
S I guess they all figured out it's a
waste of taxpayers
money Charles Arling housee is a name
known to many people here especially
those who deal with fiscal matters and I
can see the folks that are some of who
are still here um know who he is he's
the commissioner of
administrative
Services state law describes the
commissioner as say quote the chief
fiscal planning and control officer of
the
state the Department's role includes
managing and analyzing the
financial fiscal administrative
operational functions of the state
including the state budget accounting
and Reporting financial and human
resources Etc I could go on he's also
the former president of uh the Josiah
Bartlett Center
so the program we're talking about the
office of Cost Containment is under his
Direction it's in his
bureau he came to a house
Judiciary and
testified on Bill HB
611 that the program should be
eliminated and it should be eliminated
as soon as possible now he's not one of
those department heads that says make my
department larger and larger and larger
he tells it like it is and like the old
EF Hutton commercial when commissioner
Arling house talks everybody
listens I don't always agree with him
but when he and I are on the same page
and I have 35 years experience with this
issue I hope it means
something so if you want to join the
commissioner and end a useless State
program and reassign a couple of
government employees to do something
useful and if you feel somehow it's
wrong for the state to Dun and harass
innocent granted state taxpayers for
money then please vote against this grow
the state program Amendment so that the
original bill with a different Amendment
supported by commissioner Arling house
can be brought forward thank you and I
ask for a division
vote representative Linds recogniz speak
and support of the
amendment thank you Mr
Speaker I think it's important to
understand what's going on
here if you go back to
2020 the legislature when it was in
control of our friends on this side of
the
aisle passed law that effectively broke
what had been a reasonably
well-functioning system before then that
wasn't costing more to collect money
than the money that was collected U by
passing legislation in
2020 the effect of that legislation was
as my colleague just mentioned to do two
he he only mentioned one thing but it
actually did two things the first thing
it did was to say that in order for you
to have an obligation to reimburse the
state for the council Services you are
provided if you're accused of a crime
you must not you must have been
convicted now on one if you stop and
think of that you don't really think
about it for a minute you might say well
what's wrong with that but stop and
think about that that that would apply
only to someone who gets the services of
a free lawyer from the state if you or I
are charged with a crime and we have to
pay for our own lawyer and we are found
not guilty do you think we get to charge
we we got to pay our lawyer and we don't
get to ask the state for
reimbursement it's completely unfair
because remember we're talking about
people who have an ability to pay if
they they may may not be rich they may
have to take time to pay but they have
the ability to pay there's no reason for
those people not to be able to pay the
second and probably more important thing
that that 202 legislation did is it
effectively removed the ability of the
office of Cost Containment to
investigate if you will to verify
whether somebody actually had the
ability to pay or not so what what's
really important to understand about
this is that the way the initial
determination is of whether somebody is
eligible for appointed counsel or not
they file a financial affidavit
and the reality of the situation is that
there is no investigation by the court
of that financial affidavit and I'm not
faulting the court for doing that they
just they have neither the time nor the
resources and and except in a very rare
case where it's a financial crime nobody
is looking into the the uh defendant's
financial situation when I was a judge I
signed hundreds probably thousands of
appointment of counsel things and it was
based only on the face of the affidavit
and so unless you know I suppose if Bill
Gates came in and tried to file a
financial affidavit somebody would look
at it but if it's if it's if it's
something short of that nobody looks at
it and what the 2020 Amendment did was
effectively say the department of
administrative Services the OCC will not
be able to do that either and of course
as a result of all that the collections
sign of both of those factors the
connection the collections significantly
dropped from what they had been before
so for example commissioner Arling by
the way I have to say commissioner
Arling housee I reviewed the the
transcript of the hearing last night he
did not say he supported this but he
took no position on the bill what he
said is if we were going to leave the
origin the system that was established
in
2020 in place then it made no sense to
continue the office of the Cost
Containment but he also said for example
before that
2020 uh amendment was enacted the the
office of Cost Containment con collected
like two $2.5 million I believe he said
eight years ago and even four years ago
as shown in the fiscal note they
collected nearly $2
million after the legislature in 2020
broke the system last year they
collected about
$300,000 which was less than which was
which was Co which was more than I mean
less than what they expended so what
this amendment does is it restores the
law to what it was before 20120 when the
system worked I ask you to please press
the green button to support this
amendment so we can get the system back
working again thank you and Mr Speaker I
asked for a division vote
the questions on the adoption of
amendment 06 38h and this will be a
division vote members take your
seats
e
e e
the questions on the adoption of
amendment
06388 and this is a division vote
representative sher's recognized for a
parliamentary
inquiry thank you Mr Speaker uh if I
know that 25 to 30% of every one who is
appointed a public defender or a court
appointed
lawyer is found not guilty or all their
charges are dismissed yet under this
amendment they would have to pay the
state back for that which they had no
control over that is somebody deciding
that they got
charged
uh if I were to know that my estimable
colleague from Windam is just wrong when
he says that judges don't review in
detail the financial
affidavits he is
right before
2020 when judges automatically appointed
Council and then
automatically uh uh ordered
payment at the time
he was on the bench it was
automatic if I were to
know that since
2020 judges considered the financial
affidavit at sentencing rather than at
the beginning of the case if I were to
know that when they did that they uh
they were not a point they were not
charging money to the defendant would I
then uh press the red button and vote no
on
this representative cabs recognized for
parliamentary
inquiry thank you Mr Speaker Mr Speaker
if I know that this amendment is a
matter of fairness and reasonableness as
it places individuals who receive state
appointed counsel in the same position
as those who retain private counsel and
if I know that it's only fair for an
individual to cover their own expenses
if they have the means as opposed to
relying on their neighbors to do so than
when I now press the green button thank
you Mr
Speaker the questions on the adoption of
amendment 06 38h this is division vote
if you're in favor press the green
button opposed press the red voting
stations are open for 30
seconds e
[Music]
have all members present had an
opportunity to vote the house will
attend of the state of the
vote one 97 in the affirmative 163 in
the negative the Amendments adopted the
bill is on second reading and open the
further Amendment representative
margerie Smith moves Amendment 0611 H
printed in house record 15 on page 57
and is recognized to speak
Mr
Speaker when this bill was heard by the
Judiciary
Committee there was a very good turnout
of members of the the committee it is
unfortunate that the chair who has led
us so well was not able to be present
but he was able to watch the tape later
and that's
important during the hearing ing the
commissioner of
administration
said that this matter could be handled
best if he could be involved in an
amendment that would have the most
efficient and effective and responsible
way of getting rid of this uh Cost
Containment effort and making it
possible for him to transfer the
employees of that department to other
places where they
could more effectively meet the needs of
the
state that is the language that you see
in the amendment before you now it is
the language that the commissioner of
administrative Services
asked he is struggling as all of us are
to figure out the best way to address
the needs of the state when we have less
money to control than we had in the last
few
years I
respect the commissioner of
administration who I've worked with for
many years I was happy to prepare the
amendment that he requested and that is
the amendment that is before you that
amendment was um drafted by OSS it was
cleared by the
commissioner and uh then brought to the
Judiciary
Committee what Then followed was the
very well-respected chair of the
committee came in with an amendment that
completely eliminated the bill that had
been in the he in and changed reversed
180 what the bill was designed to do
and at the executive session the last
moment brought that bill to the
committee which then passed and this is
one of the very few
bills that has come to Judiciary which
left with a partisan vote unlike almost
all of the bills that we've had where we
have almost and sometimes complete
unanimity I ask you out of respect to
the work of the committee out of respect
to the commissioner of administrative
services that in fact you support this
amendment thank you Mr
Speaker representative Lind recognized
the
speaker thank you Mr speaker um with
with respect deference to my uh friend
from Durham who just spoke I think it's
important to understand two things first
if we were to pass this amendment it's
completely inconsistent with what we
just did and with respect to
commissioner Arling house I I share the
prior speakers I have great respect I've
known him for a long time I have great
respect for him again I would remind you
that what he was talking about in
suggesting CH you know the change that
that the prior speaker referenced to all
of that was based on the assumption that
that basically the law as the as our
friends on the other side of the aisle
amended it in 2020 which effectively
broke the system that that law was going
to stay in place and he basically said
look if we're going to have a if we're
going to continue to have a system that
doesn't work then then let's not let's
just get rid of it but that he was not
in any way suggesting that if the if the
amendment that we just passed to return
the law to what it used to be was in
effect that then he would do the things
he uh that was just referred to the
system was working before 2020 and the
the amendment we just passed will
restore it to the way it was but this
amendment is that was just offered is
completely inconsistent with that I ask
you to press the red button thank you
and Mr Speaker I request uh division
vote of division vote thank you so say
you
all questions on the adoption of
amendments 0611 H and everybody wants a
division vote so members take your
seats e
the question is on the adoption of
amendment
H representative margerie Smith's
recognized for parliamentary
inquiry Mr
Speaker if you
know that the bill
started at facing
north that an amendment came
in to make the bill face
South and if you
know that the
second no let me not word it that way
the amendment that came before us after
the first
amendment turn turn us back to North
where we had started when the bill was
first submitted would you now let us
continue going upwards in the right
direction and support this
amendment thank you and I have we
already asked for a division if so we
could divide it again thank
you representative kabs recognized for
parliamentary
inquiry thank you Mr Speaker Mr Speaker
if I
know excuse me that this amendment
undoes everything the previous Amendment
just fixed would I now press the red
button so we can move forward in the
right direction thank
you the question is on the adoption of
amendment 06118 and this is a division
vote if you're in favor pressing green
button oppos press the red voting
stations are open for 30 seconds
should
have all members present had an
opportunity to vote the house attend to
the state of the vote
165 and the affirmative 196 and the
negative the amendment
fails brings us now back to the main
motion of a to pass as amended by 0638
Hest for division we have a request for
a division while everybody's in their
seats this will be a division vote
last for
questions on the majority committee
report about to pass on House Bill 611
representative Shar is recognized for
parliamentary
inquiry thank you Mr Speaker if I know
that a uh rejection of this bill
otpa uh would result in US returning to
a system where the judge would consider
the financial affidavit uh and whether
to send it to the office of Cost
Containment uh in depth if I know that
would occur at the sentencing hearing
when the judge was also making
determinations about whether to find the
person and whether that person should
pay restitution if I know that that's
what would happen if you press uh the
red button and vote no I ask you to do
so thank
you representative Cav is recognized for
a parliamentary inquiry thank you Mr
Speaker Mr Speaker if I know that this
bill will return us back to a system of
financial fairness and responsibility
then would I now press the green
button questions on the majority
committee report have ought to pass as
amended as a division vote if you're in
favor press the green button oppos press
the red voting stations are open for 30
seconds
[Music]
represent br
have all members present and an
opportunity to vote house will attend to
the state of the vote
199 and the affirmative 163 and the
negative the report is
adopted House Bill 611 is referred to
the committee on
finance for what reason does the member
rise thank you Mr Speaker I Rise to make
a motion to allow the hot tlemen to
remove their jackets with the exception
of when speaking at the well without
objection
the committee on Judiciary ises referred
as Bill 615 FN an act relative to drug
forfeiture proceedings having considered
the same report the same with the
following resolution resolved that it is
inexpedient to legislate representative
margerie Smith for the committee for
what reason does the member rise to lay
HB 615 on the table please
representative Osborne moves to lay
House Bill 615 on the table are you
ready for the question divisions been
requested members take your seats
ey
the question is whether to lay House
Bill 615 on the table representative Dan
Maguire is recognized for parliamentary
inquiry thank you Mr Speaker Mr Speaker
if I know that the legal profession
likes length but that the legislature
likes brevity and if I know that uh
lawyers helped me draft this
bill um and if and if I know that I
would like to deny myself the pleasure
of debating this bill for the next 10 to
15 minutes would I now press the green
button representative margorie Smith's
recognized for parliamentary inquiry Mr
Speaker if I always know that it's a
pleasure to hear from our colleag
league and Mr Speaker if I know that the
reason we have so many lawyers in this
state in this country is that when
there's a lawyer on any one side there
are lawyers on seven other sides so the
fact that lawyers were involved in
drafting it doesn't convince me even
though I was married to one for almost
50 years and finally finally Mr Speaker
if I know that if we accept the
committee position of it Ling this bill
we would leave our colleague free from
now until the beginning of the next
session to come in with a very different
bill that addresses a very in important
issue and that is how we handle drug
forfeiting uh therefore I would ask you
to vote no on the tabling
motion and I also Mr Speaker a apologize
because I believe that I said you not I
in my last pi and that's only because I
know how important you are thank
you well here we
are the motion is to lay House Bill 615
on the table it's a division vote if
you're in favor press the green button
oppos press the red voting stations are
open for 30 seconds
[Music]
have all members present had an
opportunity to vote the house will
attend of the state of the
vote 195 in the affirmative 163 and the
negative House Bill 65 is laid on the
table
the majority of the committee on
Judiciary to which is referred House
Bill 762 FNA an act appropriating
$30,000 to the judicial branch for the
purpose of hiring a contractor conduct a
manual review of domestic violence and
stalking cases and related criminal
cases having considered the same report
the same with the following resolution
resolved that it is inexpedient to
legislate representative Joe Alexander
for the majority of the committee the
minority of the committee having
considered the same and being unable to
agree with the majority Report with the
following amendments and the
recommendation that the bill ought to
pass with a Amendment representative Zoe
Manos for the minority of the committee
for what reason does the member R thank
you seeing a lot of room left on the
table I move to lay HB 762 on
it represent Osborne moves to lay House
Bill 762 on the table are you ready for
the question oh
yeah all right division why
not this will be a division vote if
you're not in your seat find it quick
on
the question is ready the lay House Bill
762 on the table representative
Alexander is recognized for
parliamentary inquiry thank you Mr
Speaker Mr Speaker if I know that I sit
on the Judiciary Committee and I'm
exhausted listening to Judiciary
Committee bills and the table is very
large would I then press the green
button to put this St on the table
representative Rambo's recognized for
parliamentary
inquiry thank you Mr Speaker Mr Speaker
if I know that this is a very limited
Bill to hear for limited funding uh to
support domestic violence victims and to
provide data on cases that we do not
currently have the ability to analyze
would I red to defeat the tling
motion thank
you the questions whether the L House
Bill 762 on the table this is a division
vote if you're in favor press the green
button if you're opposed press the red
voting stations are open for 30 seconds
[Music]
have all members present had an
opportunity to vote the house will
attend to the state of the vote
199 in the affirmative 160 in the
negative House Bill 762 is laid on the
table
ready
the majority of the committee on
Municipal and County government to which
was referred House Bill 149 FN an act
relative to Warrant article approvals at
ballot referenda form of town meeting
having considered the same report the
same with the following resolution
resolved that is inexpedient to
legislate representative Julie Gilman
for the majority of the committee the
minority of the the committee having
considered the same being unable to
agree with the majority Report with the
recommendation that the bill ought to
pass representative Diane power for the
minority of the
committee yep questions on the motion of
inexpedient to legislate the chair
recommend uh recognizes representative
sellers to speak against the Comm
committee
report thank you Mr
Speaker I'm bringing uh HB
149 trying to turn it over to another
motion because it is a really good B
Bill a nice thing to have in your
toolbox especially during voting time
for towns and and uh school districts HB
149 it's not a par bill it actually
solves a problem that H happens to many
of us in our uh SP2 towns and school
districts the bill is about giving the
voters the final say in which articles
they want to go forward
just uh go excuse me go forward it not
just the amended article that you have
which would be the final article from a
deliberative session so here's four
points on the
bill one both the original and the
amended AR articles are to be placed on
the ballot two if both versions are of
the article are approved the version
with the highest percentage of yes votes
of the total yes no votes is
adopted three in the in the slight
chance of a tie the amended version is
adopted this is the same as a question
that's being defeated where the amended
version from the deliberative session
which was the final version at the
deliver session is actually
approved so four the version will be
each version will be clearly labeled one
will say original and the other will say
amended This Is A New Concept but it's
not cumbersome it's actually pretty
straightforward HB 149 allows for the
greater number of Voters to determine
what the best for their town or School
District at The Ballot Box this is part
of democracy this is our democracy
that's what I would think it would be
giving us the best choice for our towns
and schools here's an example of a
delivered ass session that happens and
may happen to some of you out there at
delivered ass session there's a there's
a warrant article and it basically says
and and I'm shortening it greatly it
says there's a 3% tax cap they're asking
for a 3% tax cap to be approved by the
voters well at the deliver the session
someone goes and actually makes an
amendment and amends that warrant tical
so now it says uh and it's been approved
and now it says the the article now says
that will you will you approve a 50% tax
cap so now you have the original and you
have the amended both of those will go
forward on the ballot all right one's at
3% one's at 50 one says original and one
says
amended you can see here the
voters uh may vote for both of them or
they may vote Yes for both yes for one
or the other no for both or no for one
of the other you can also see by this
amendment it could be um viewed as kind
of vindictive in a way that purposely
disenfranchises the voters at the ballot
because if this was the amended version
was the only one that goes forward which
that's what happens today then you only
have the 50% tax cap to choose from and
really the person or the or the um or
the uh select board a school board
actually wanted a 3% tax cap to go
board I'm just going to
say this is not even close to rank
Choice voting so that I think they'll
having a build next week on
that and in in this simple bill you can
see the democracy at work that allows
all the voters to determine what is best
for their Town School District it also
controls those who purposely derail good
warrant articles by frivolous amendments
to per uh to preemptively defeat uh
articles disenfranchising the
voters colleagues I'm just saying
this we're going to have a rebuttal to
my speech here now I'm saying don't let
them confuse you don't let them
complicate this muddy blur distort twist
and if I could find 10 more I put them
on there all right by whatever they say
this is a simple bill which allows for
the will of the people to decide if the
original
Amendment uh or the amend excuse me is
the original or the amended version
should go forward for their time now I
was going to ask for division but I
don't want to do that it seems like
we've had enough of them so if everybody
wants to yell nay as loud as I can we
won't have to do a division thank
you chair recognizes representative
Gilman to speak in favor of the
committee
report thank you Mr Speaker this bill
applies to official ballot referenda or
SP2 legislative bodies theb2 is a form
of governance that must be adopted by a
3 fths majority of Voters in that
Municipal municipality or School
District the the sb2 form of governance
may also resend by a 3- fths majority
that form of governance it consists of
two sessions the first session is like a
traditional town meeting warrant
articles are debated and may be amended
but before voting on the question then
these articles are forwarded to the
second session by voting by official
ballot every registered voter in the
municipality under sb2 May participate
in this process this Bill mandates that
both the original warrant articles
presented at the deliberate session and
any amended versions made at the
deliberative session must be placed
consecutively on the official ballot
This is highly problematic for several
reasons it introduces unnecessary ballot
complexity with two or more versions of
the same question on the ballot that
will only serve to confuse voters
ballots may become extensive in length
discouraging voters from considering
every article on the
ballot the bill is an unfunded mandate
by way of potentially raising costs of
the lengthy ballot printing or calling
special Town meetings to correct
mistakes in testimony submitted to the
committee the New Hampshire City and
town clerks Association opposes this
bill for these very reasons they are the
experienced professionals who prepare
ballots tally votes and budget the town
meetings or special Town meetings the
will of the deliberative session is
overruled with this bill it ignores the
right of provided an RSA 40 colon 10 for
a motion to restrict further
consideration of a proposed warrant
article at there is no provision for an
amendment's legality if an amendment
does not have the appropriate legal
wording but is approved does the m
municip ality move forward operating
illegally or call a costly special town
meeting the answer to successful warrant
article or any amendment being adopted
is not to confuse overwhelm or
disenfranchise voters but by advocacy
and Outreach or as some would call it
campaigning before the deliberative
session finally this bill is slanted
toward approving the amended amended
warrant article the bill mandates that
if a yes vote on the original and
amended versions is Tied by the same
percentage of yes votes the outcome
shall be the adoption of the amended
version in any other small D Democratic
voting as in our Comm our committees and
here in the representatives Hall a TI
vote defeats the question a percentage
should not be determine the outcome of a
tied vote
this proposed method of declaring
Victory is clear
disenfranchisement this bill not only
creates confusion but also com
compromises the integrity and the
fairness of the S SP2 legislative
process please support the committee's
vote 16-2 of inexpedient legislate thank
you Mr
Speaker question is on the committee
recommendation of inexpedient to
legislate on House Bill 149 FN
are this will be a division vote members
please take your
seats
e e
the house will come to
order the chair recognizes
representative sellers for a
parliamentary
inquiry thank you Mr
Speaker if I knew this simp Bill greatly
improves the voices of all registered
voters of an SP2 town or school district
and Mr Speaker if I knew the bill would
help put a stop to disenfranchising the
voters with ridiculous amendments at our
deliberative sessions and finally Mr
Speaker if I knew many citizens want
this bill because they are unable to
attend to deliver a session because
their dis because of their disabilities
out of town or in the military then I
would press the red button and let's
move on
chair recognizes representative Dennis
Murphy for a parliamentary
inquiry thank you Mr Speaker if I knew
that this bill would hamper all election
officials including the select in school
boards clerks and moderators and their
budgets adversely due to the printing
mail and mailing costs of the new
ballots if I knew this bill would
undermine the deliberative session and
confuse the voters at the second session
seeing both warrant
articles on the warrant if I knew this
would be creating a rank Choice system
for the warrant articles I would now
press the green button thank
you the question is on the motion of
inexpedient to legislate on House Bill
149 FN this is a division vote if you
are in favor you'll press the green
button if you're opposed you will press
the red button voting stations will be
open for 30
seconds e
[Music]
have all members present have had an
opportunity to
vote the house will attend to the state
of the
vote with 244 in the affirmative and 112
in the negative the motion
passes the committee on Municipal and
County government to which was referred
House Bill 512 FN and act relative to
preventing Municipal Employees from
being paid under multiple Municipal
contracts simultaneously having
considered the same report the same with
the following resolution resolved that
it is inexpedient to legislate
representative Dennis Murphy for the
committee the question is on the motion
of inexp inexpedient to legislate on
House Bill 512 FN are you ready for the
question all in favor say I I
all opposed say
nay the eyes have it the motion is
adopted the committee on Municipal and
County government to which was referred
House Bill 643 FN an act relative an an
act expanding the number of Grafton
County Commissioners having considered
the same report the same with the
following resolution resolved that it is
inexpedient to legislate representative
Laurel stavis for the committee
the question is on the motion of
inexpedient to legislate on House Bill
643 FN are you ready for the question
all those in favor say I I all those
opposed say
nay the eyes have it the motion is
adopted the committee on Municipal and
County government to which was referred
House Bill 668 FN local an act
authorizing municipalities to hold a
referendum to resend the licenses of
historic horse racing facilities having
considered the same report the same with
the following resolution resolved that
it is inexpedient to legislate
representative John McDonald for the
committee the motion is on the the the
the question is on the motion of
inexpedient to legislate on House Bill
668 FN local are you ready for the
question all those in favor say I
all those opposed say
nay the eyes have it the motion is
adopted the majority of the committee on
science technology and energy to which
was referred House Bill 219 FN an act
relative to the phasing out of the
minimum electric renewable portfolio
standard having considered the same
report the same with the following
Amendment and the recommendation that
the bill ought to pass with Amendment
representative Michael Harrington for
the majority of the
committee the minority of the committee
having considered the same and being
unable to agree with a majority Report
with the following resolution resolved
that it is inexpedient to legislate
representative Dale Swanson for the
minority of the committee the amendment
is
0678 H printed in house record 15 on
pages 39 and
40 the question is on the amend M on the
committee Amendment are you ready for
the question all those in favor say I I
all those oppos
nay the eyes have it the amendment is
adopted question is now on the motion of
ought to pass as
amended chair recognizes representative
McGee to speak against the committee
report
thank you Mr
Speaker HB 219 pokes holes in major
parts of the state's renewable portfolio
standard program also known as the
RPS which began in
2009 the point of having an RPS is to be
able to measure increases in clean local
energy sources as we reap the benefits
that they bring to New Hampshire what
are those benefits fuel Choice Economic
Development reduced emissions lower
dependence on outof state Imports lower
energy costs reduce demand for oil and
gas and keeping energy dollars in the
New Hampshire
economy our RPS program was set up in
perpetuity it was designed to continue
until we achieve our goals the first
goal was set up back in 2009 and it was
set to have us achieve 25% of our Energy
Mix as clean by
2025 we were not supposed to stop now as
if there's nothing more that needs to be
done um in fact New Hampshire's goal was
always seen as modest at best over that
period of
time uh currently we are behind all New
England states uh Connecticut's got a
goal of 48% by 2030 Maine is at 100% by
2050 um they've been working on their
housing sector with ground Source heat
Mass is at 55% by 2050 in Rhode Island
100% by 2030 Vermont is 75% by 2035 we
don't have a goal um and that's the
difference between us and these other
states so we're poking holes in the few
policies that we have and we're
defunding pennies uh that we're spending
to basically save people thousands with
the
RPS um New Hampshire is choosing not to
help Granite sters invest or
save the RPS had a price tag uh in 20124
of
$26 per month on an average electric
bill but it supports all those benefits
that I listed up front so it's a good
deal as amended HB 219 takes us backward
our committee leadership really doesn't
like solar so the first thing the bill
does is to eliminate solar credits
altogether Class 2 RPS Rex for solar
Gone without any analysis of what losing
those credits will do to towns and
businesses who have invested in solar
arrays uh who will no longer receive
those benefits benefits that they were
promised when they penel out those
projects I thought we were supposed to
be helping people to lower their bills
and weren't we claiming that we had an
all of thee above strategy
the second thing the bill does is it
takes the class two credits the ones
that support new renewable projects in
solar wind Hydro biomass and even
geothermal and reduces the value of
those credits back to 2011 levels rather
than increasing their already low value
in a regional market this is the literal
definition of
regression um rather than support
investment in new local energy that
lowers cost costs and increases
Independence our goal is to go the other
way with this bill we're saying with
this bill we want to be last in the
region when it comes to energy policy
and the most vulnerable to the volatile
energy markets think our bills that
doubled in
2022 how do you think this gutting of
the RPS will play into the decisions of
Business Leaders who realize outof
control energy costs are a lock in New
Hampshire due to the lack of choice and
the lack of State energy strategy some
solar is a sound option for some
sometimes solar is a sound option but
with this bill we take it off the table
for those who would choose it we change
the economics so the Investments are
unlikely HB 219 upends the stability of
individuals towns and businesses who
want to generate energy to avoid
volatile fuel prices lowering class one
credits for new renewable Investments
when they should be going up sends the
signal that we don't want to invest and
we don't want anyone else to invest the
point of the RPS is to increase our
goals until our emissions go down but
instead of setting goals for the next
10e period we're opting to stop
measuring alog
together if you believe in cheap energy
that's local and clean to help lower our
energy bills and lower our emissions
then I now ask you to push the red
button so a better motion can be made
and I ask for a roll
call Representative Harrington is
recognized to speak in favor of the
committee report thank you Mr Speaker
good afternoon boy that was quite a
speech um I was hoping to be here
talking about actually phasing out of
the renewable portfolio standard because
I think the residents of New Hampshire
can smart enough to decide what type of
electricity to buy by themselves without
the government telling them who so but
that is not the case so what we are here
to talk about is acps Rec's different
classes um and all and rpss now you all
want a detailed explanation of what they
are and how they work but too bad you're
not going to get
one and that's because it's not going to
make any difference on how anybody votes
practically here's what's important
about this bill it's going to save about
$5.7 million a year for rate payers it
makes no large changes to anything no
business will be negatively affected by
this uh I know there's uh counties out
there and municipalities that use the
useful thermal energy because they have
boilers and they get subsidies from rate
payers those will continue they will not
be decreased whatsoever we have the
target for useful thermal energy is so
high that we have less than half of the
amount of wrecks being fulfilled so
there's plenty of room for growth even
with the decrease and all we're doing is
spending the buying alternate compliance
payments to make up the rest of it which
is costing us millions of dollars in
taxes to it so I urge you to vote green
but I'll warn you if you do vote red
I'll be back with a big explanation of
all those things I just mentioned so you
don't want that vote
green representative McGee has requested
a roll call vote is that sufficiently
seconded it is sufficiently seconded
this will be a roll call vote members
please take your
seats
e
e e
the house will come to
order the chair recognizes
representative McGee I'm sorry uh
representative Swanson for a
parliamentary inquiry
thank you Mr
Speaker if I know that the renewable
portfolio standard which has been in
place since its bipartisan introduction
in 2009 promotes the goal of reducing
New Hampshire Reliance on imported
non-renewable fossil fuel energy and if
I know that Granite Staters are the
primary
beneficiaries of the renewable energy
and the economic investment that this
standard creates and if I know that this
bill would eliminate credits for solar
and it would just give pennies back to
rate payers without addressing the
vulnerabilities to costly natural gas
price spikes as happened in
2022 then would I press the red button
to defeat this bill so another motion
can be made
chair recognizes representative V for a
parliamentary
inquiry thank you Mr Speaker Mr Speaker
if I know that our state's Governor has
urged us not to mass up New
Hampshire and if I also know that green
energy policy in Massachusetts now
accounts for almost
30% of an electric bill what I now press
the green button to adopt these modest
reforms to New Hampshire green energy
policy and save our rate payers $57
million over the next 10 years thank you
Mr
Speaker question is on the majority
committee report of of ought to pass
with Amendment on House Bill 219 FN this
is a roll call vote if you're in favor
you'll press the green button if you're
opposed you'll press the red button
voting stations are open for 30
seconds e
[Music]
have all members present had an
opportunity to
vote the house will attend to the state
of the
vote with 189 members voting in the
affirmative 173 voting in the negative
the motion is adopted House Bill 219 FN
will be referred to the committee on
finance
the committee on science technology and
energy to which was referred as Bell 6
696 FN an act exempting electricity
generators from the utility property tax
and including them under the state
education property tax and relative to
communication Services tax revenues
having considered the same report the
same with the recommendation at the bill
ought to pass representative Michael vot
for the committee the questions on the
majority committee report of ought to
pass you ready for the question all
those in favor say I I all those oppose
nay guys have it and the committee
reports adopted out spel 696 is referred
to the committee on ways and means
for reason does a member rise no all
right the majority of the committee on
science technology and energy to which
was referred outp 764
FN an act prohibiting the intentional
release of polluting emissions including
cloud seating weather modification
excessive electromagnetic radio
frequency microwave radiation and making
penalties for violation of such
prohibition having considered the same
report the same with the following
resolution resolved that it is
inexpedient to legislate representative
Thomas Corman for the majority of the
committee the minority of the committee
having considered the same and being
unable to agree with the majority Report
with the recommendation at the bill
ought to pass representative Tom plaz
for the minority of the committee
for what reason does a member
rise for a motion Mr Speaker State your
motion I move that we lay house bills
764 on the table representative Weber
moves to lay House Bill 764 on the table
ready for the question V oh and she
wants a division vote this will be a
division vote members take your seats
us
the questions weather layous Bill 764 on
the table representative partials
recognized for parliamentary inquiry
Mr
Speaker if I know there have been marks
safe from excessive electromagnetic
radio frequency and microwave radiation
today and further if I know that the
intentional release of polluting
emissions is already regulated with
sufficient ambiguity and this build does
nothing to
clarify uh sad emissions
and finally if I know it's contrails not
Chemtrails and its geoengineering is not
cloud seesing and this bill that seeks
to prevent man-made weather changes is
unnecessary as I have been repeatedly
told by my more reparable colleagues
across the aisle that we lack their
technological capacity to affect climate
change then would I now push the green
button to uphold the overwhelmingly
bipartisan committee
recommendation represent Bernard is
recognized for parliamentary
inquiry thank you Mr Speaker uh I Rise
to ask you to overturn this table or not
accept the table uh parli if I know if I
know uh that this bill the underlying
Bill deals with a basic platform issue
here uh and it does two things one it
repeals a chapter on weather
experimentation in the state
and two it sends a message to federal
agencies that New Hampshire is not open
for geo
engineering if I know that those are the
case that's what this bill does I'd ask
you to vote red to not table this motion
this
bill the question is whether they House
Bill 764 on the table this a division
vote if you're in favor press the green
button oppos press the red voting
stations are open for 30 seconds
[Music]
have all members present had an
opportunity to vote house will attend to
the state of the vote 205 in the
affirmative 158 and the negative 764 is
laid on the table
chair recognizes the clerk thank you Mr
Speaker I have a letter from the chair
of the committee on finance pursuant to
house rule 47f House Bill 592 is waved
as a second committee
Bill the committee on state federal
relations and Veterans Affairs to which
was referred House Bill 264 FN an act
relative to delegates to an article 5
convention having considered the same
report the same with the recommendation
that the bill ought to pass
representative Tom Manion for the
committee for what reason does a member
rise I move to table House Bill
264 the motion is to table House Bill
264 you ready for the question all those
in favor say I I any oppos nay no the
eyes have it 264 is laid on the table
the majority of the committee on
Transportation who ises referred House
Bill 452 FN an act relative to the
issuance of drivers licenses for aliens
temporary residing in New Hampshire
having considered the same report the
same with the recommendation that the
bill ought to pass representative Thomas
Walsh for the majority of the committee
the minority of the committee having
considered the same and being unable to
agree with the majority Report with the
following resolution resolved that it is
inexpedient to legislate representative
Seth Miller for the minority of the
committee representative U is recognized
to speak against the committee
report thank you Mr Speaker I rise in
opposition to the OTP motion on House
Bill
452 HB 452 would prohibit as siles
people who have been granted asylum in
the US or here seeking Asylum from
obtaining a New Hampshire driver's
license until they have been granted
full permanent residency a green
card even though once they' have been
granted Asylum they don't have to apply
for a green card to stay here
permanently and legally even if they
already received work
authorization this bill prevents them
from renewing a driver's license they
already
have now before I get too far along in
this I want you to do something for me
picture in your mind what a refugee
looks like where they come
from what led them here now picture an
asylum Seeker or an asy where are they
from what led them here if the image in
your mind is the same for both you're
absolutely right because there is no
difference it's the same process the
same screening the same legal
protections but under this bill they are
treated very
differently now imagine two twin sisters
they're born in the same Village raised
by the same parents attend the same
schools one is there when War breaks out
her home is destroyed her life is in
danger she has no choice but to
flee she makes her way to a un aid
station where she applies for Refugee
status her case is processed she is
legally admitted to the United States
sent right here to New Hampshire to live
with relatives her twin sister
she's already here visiting those same
relatives on illegal visa when that War
Began but now returning home is no
longer an option for
her instead fleeing to instead of
fleeing to a un Camp she does what the
law allows she goes to a US immigration
office and applies for
Asylum two sisters same country same
crisis same risk if they return home yet
this under this bill they are treated
very
differently both received work
authorization on the same day but under
this bill only one of them can get a
driver's license the other same
circumstances
cannot the only difference between them
where they happen to be standing when
the war broke
out the ultimate result of this bill is
not improve Public Safety or greater
fairness it simply creates a legal
trap we know that in order to survive
asiles have to work and to work in New
Hampshire people need to drive that's
the
reality unlike refugees who receive
federal resettlement assistance ases do
not no housing no food benefits no
financial support while they wait for
the cases to be heard they're expected
to support themselves and when they
finally receive work authorization they
must work because they have no other
choice but this bill doesn't acknowledge
reality it creates obstacles it doesn't
make us safer it makes our roads more
dangerous it doesn't protect the law it
undermines it it doesn't treat people
equally it punishes those who apply for
protection from within our borders
now let's look at the consequences if
this bill were about Public Safety we
would want drivers to be trained tested
and
insured instead it leaves practically no
choice but for them to drive without a
license increasing the risk on our
roads If This Were about protecting
Integrity of our the Integrity of our
laws we would respect the process that
is already determined that these
individuals have a right to be here
instead it seeks to override that
process with state level
bureaucracy If This Were about
fairness it wouldn't single out one
group of lawfully present people while
allowing others in the same situation to
drive so what is the real impact this
bill creates legal
traps it forces people into impossible
choices follow this law and lose your
ability to work break it and face a
misdemeanor
charge and what happens with that
misdemeanor their Asylum case is denied
their ability to stay in this country is
jeopardized the system they trusted has
now turned against
them we heard this bill last term and we
are told this version is different we're
told this version is more refined
because it now distinguishes between
Asylum Seekers and ases or
refugees but we have just demonstrated
that they're the same thing same legal
standards same burden of proof same
Federal determination that they need
protection yet we've heard the claim
that Asylum Seekers are merely lawfully
present not here legally I'm not sure
what that
means this is a false distinction in MO
in a majority of cases ases win their
cases they stay here there is no basis
for the claim that Asylum Seekers are
lying on mass it is not supported by
credible data most Asylum denials
denials are not based on are not because
of false claims but because of
technicalities the process is
complicated and difficult to navigate
without a lawyer
sies who try to represent themselves
Miss deadlines paperwork is incorrect
people struggle to meet legal burdens
that shift from Administration to
Administration this bill assumes that
Asylum Seekers are frauds but the facts
tell us that most are not so what is
this bill really doing it's creating
unnecessary
barriers one group of people legally
present federally authorized to work
will be allowed to drive another group
legally present federally authorized to
work will be denied that same right
we should not be in the business of
making life harder for people simply
because of where they were standing when
they applied for
protection and we should not be in the
business of setting legal traps that
serve no purpose but to punish those who
have followed the rules for these
reasons I urge this body to reject HB
452 thank you Mr Speaker and I request a
division
vote representative wal's recognized
speak in support of the committee report
thank you Mr
Speaker this is actually a very simple
and a pretty common sense and a pretty
fair Bill the two main things that it do
does number one it organizes the
criteria needed for aliens temporarily
residing in New Hampshire to acquire
driver's license currently those that
criteria is scattered all over the
statute uh it also requires uh it also
states that the director of Motor
Vehicles shall consider this criteria
not May which is currently in statute I
could never figure out what good
statutory requirements are if there's a
word May in front of it the second thing
it does as you heard a minute ago it is
true the bill also clarifies when an
alien claiming Asylum can acquire a New
Hampshire driver's
license the reason this only deals with
uh people claiming Asylum as you were
just told there is a difference or there
is no difference there's a huge
difference between somebody claiming
Refugee status because that's done in
their their country of origin they just
don't show up at a Port of
Entry let's during the four years of the
Biden Administration we watched as
millions of migrants stormed our borders
most requested Asylum uh and and again
specifically that is fear legally fear
of persecution politically or for
religious reasons seeking a better life
is not a legitimate reason to request
Asylum whether they came here through a
checkpoint snuck in the oldfashioned way
or just didn't want to go home when
their visa expired the Biden
Administration was happy to honor these
requests for Asylum which grants them
lawful presence it's an i589 form that's
the document that takes place at the
border well then again like I said you
didn't even if you came in the under a
fence you could use the Biden app and
request Asylum and they would give it to
you
um so while they have this lawful
presence that is supposedly while they
wait for their court date it is at the
immigration courts that they have to
prove that they hear IL legally so
there's a big difference between lawful
presence which is what is Twisted to
mean legal nowadays it's not true the
court is where you prove your
legal because of the years of delays in
the immigration courts obviously because
the system is overwhelmed I contend by
Design the Biden Administration began
the ex uh the expit issuance of
temporary work authorizations
these authorizations come with a social
security number this is the trigger that
enables them to get a license a the
Hampshire license and it is the loophole
that this bill seeks to
close the majority of the committee
believes it is unfair to the L biting
citizens that the privilege to drive is
being given to people who haven't even
proven they are here legally we also
believe that our new Bo our new borders
are Tom Holman when he estimates that
nine out of 10 of these Asylum requests
are illegitimate please support the
majority committee report of ought to
pass thank you Mr
Speaker the questions on the majority
committee report have ought to pass
divisions been requested this will be a
division vote members take your seats
[Music]
representative cab sees your Division
and raises you a roll call is that
sufficiently seconded and it is this
will be a roll call vote members
continue taking your seats e
clear the questions on the majority
committee report have about to pass on
House Bill
452 representative Miller is recognized
for a parliamentary
inquiry thank you Mr
Speaker if I know that this bill is bad
for the economy of New Hampshire pulling
workers out of our businesses and
shoppers out of our stores and if I know
that this bill perverts our legal system
trying to override federal laws
Association associated with the
definition of asylum and likely violates
our constitution by creating two classes
of granite Staters declaring people
guilty without trial and without the
chance of
appeal and if I know that excuse me and
if I know that the majority testified in
committee that this bill does nothing to
improve the safety on our roads and in
our communities would I then press the
red button to reject the OTP motion so a
more Humane and more reasonable motion
can be considered thank you
representative Gorski is recognized for
parliamentary
inquiry thank you Mr Speaker Mr Speaker
if I know that this bill does not allow
the DMV to provide driver's licenses to
any person who cannot prove lawful
permanent residents in the
USA and if I know that this bill does
not allow a driver's license to a
non-resident alien to be used as valid
ID of residence for voting purposes and
finally if I know this bill will not
allow a license to be granted to a
person who's granted ay status by a us
custom and Immigration Services until
the application as a lawful permanent
resident of a USA has been granted in
fully vetted then would I press the
green button to support the OTP motion
thank thank you Mr
Speaker the questions on the majority
committee report of ought to pass an
House Bill 452 it's a roll call vote if
you're in favor press the green button
oppos press the red voting stations are
open for 30 seconds
[Music]
have all members present had an
opportunity to vote the house will
attend to the state of the
vote 198 in the affirmative 162 in the
negative the committee reports adopted
Finance House Bill 452 is referred to
the committee on finance
the committee on ways and means to which
was referred House Bill 658 FN an act
raising the cap on certain
reimbursements from the oil discharge
and Disposal cleanup fund having
considered the same report the same with
the recommendation that the bill ought
to pass representative Scott Brier for
the committee questions on the majority
committee report have ought to pass you
ready for the question all those in
favor say I I any oppose nay the eyes
have the committee reports
adopted chair recognizes the clerk thank
you Mr Speaker I have a note from the
chair of the committee on finance who
has waved the second committee uh
referral of House Bill 452 pursuant to
house rule
47f the committee on waves and means to
which referred House Bill 669 FNA an act
relative to requiring all revenue raised
under the Statewide education property
tax to be deposited in the education
trust fund and setting an equalized
Statewide tax rate having considered the
same report the same with the following
resolution resolve that it is
inexpedient to legislate representative
Jordan oy for the
committee representative wheeler is
recognized speak against the committee
report
thank you Mr
Speaker Mr
Speaker I am told
247 by my constituents and the districts
around me that our property taxes in
this state are too high and this
legislation HB
669 aims to address that now in 1999
there was legislation passed HB
999 by the house finance committee at
the time it was called House
Appropriations and this bill in 1999
created a
660 equalized valuation rate for our
Statewide property taxes now in 1996
1997 1998 there was a certain property
tax rate once that legislation was
passed HB 999 in 1999 in a Republican
legisl
those property taxes went down it is
possible this is something that can
happen we hear all the time our property
taxes our property taxes we can bring
our property taxes in this state down we
currently have a Statewide property tax
rate that is unequal that is taxing
people at an unequal rate and that tax
rate is anti-constitutional it's against
part two Article Five of the
Constitution which says that taxes in
this state should be fair and
proportional the tax rate in this state
right now doesn't matter if you're on
the majority party the minority party
doesn't matter if you're a Libertarian
or a socialist it's
unfair it's an unfair tax rate and it
leaves us in a place where people who
have fixed incomes people who have lived
in this state for their entire lives I
think of my neighbor who grew up in her
house who raised her son in her house
who tells me that and I'm not sure she
voted for me but she likes talking to me
she tells me that she isn't going to be
able to stay in her house much longer if
the tax rate keeps going up in the way
that it is this legislation HB 669 would
set forth an equalized valuation rate of
$5 per 1,000 now what that would do is
mean that some richer towns in our state
most of them on this side of the aisle
would pay a higher tax rate but would
also mean that those poor towns in our
state which are seriously overburdened
right now would pay a lower tax rate it
would equalize the valuation and make it
a fair tax across the board that to me
is a very important thing when we're
talking about the fact that the
constitution and the people who put it
together outlined that taxes in this
state should be done in a fair and
proportional way this legislation sets
them up in a fair and proportional way
if you hear nothing else from my speech
today I hope that you go and watch the
ways and means hearing from February the
12th at 1M it's on the YouTube and
listen to the members who brought this
forward the representative who was there
in 1999 from the majority party who
helped bring this forward to try and get
this done again when we passed this in
1999 we saw a reduction in property
taxes in every town in this state and we
can do that again if we have an
equalized valuation rate passed here
today this legislation would lower the
property tax burden and it would make
the state more flush with cash as the
chairman for division one called it in
his testimony for this hearing and I see
him smiling right now because he knows
what I'm going to say this is a piece of
very tasty chocolate cake it's tempting
but I would only disagree in one place I
think this is a little bit heartier a
meal than a piece of chocolate cake
because this addresses a problem that
our constituents have asked us to
address adnasium
please lower my property tax rate make
it a fair rate where poor towns aren't
paying the burden for Rich towns and
where every taxpayer in this state play
pays the same rate as the other nobody
should be paying a higher rate in taxes
than another for a Statewide tax nobody
should be thinking this is a donor Town
situation there are no donor towns in
this state last time I checked I pay
taxes individually and then those taxes
go to the state the municipalities don't
touch that money so what we have to do
here today and as I said please watch
the
hearing 2:12 at 1 p.m. on house Ways and
Means and listen to the people who in
1999 did the work to pass this equalized
valuation rate which resulted in a
reduction of property taxes so I would
ask that you stand with me and our
constituents who are asking us for us to
reduce their property taxes and finally
get this state in a place where we are
in a constitutional tax system that
taxes people fairly and proportionately
as outlined in our constitution as
opposed to allowing the poor towns to
take the burden for all of us thank you
Mr Speaker and I ask that you vote
against the committee report to overturn
it and move it on to an a to pass to get
it off to the Senate division vote and I
would like a division vote
thank you Mr representative malloy's
recognized speak against the committee
report I'm speaking in support
the
that's sorry sorry yes thank you my
mistake Mr Speaker I raise to speak in
support of the uh committee report of
itl while we often disagree in this room
about the best way to fund public
education and how much funding the state
should
provide I think we we can agree that the
current funding system is
broken this bill seeks to address
inequities in the way schools are
funded by significantly increasing the
amount raised by the state I commend the
sponsors for bringing this concept into
the
conversation this bill is not the right
approach first it brings back the
concept of donor towns which would harm
many communities including the ones I
represent this bill would also raise the
Statewide education property tax tax to
$5 per thousand more than quadrupling
the swept rate of
a112 that we have today per
thousand simply put the property
taxpayers of New Hampshire cannot afford
this bill please join me in pressing the
green button to support the itl motion
thank you Mr
Speaker representative oer is recognized
to speak for the committee report
I could but then again I
will okay go with
division nope representative wheeler
requests a roll call is that
sufficiently seconded
nope nope uh it'll be a division vote
though all right this will be a division
vote members take your
seats e
questions on the majority committee
report have been expedient to legislate
on House Bill 669 representative wheeler
recognized for a parliamentary inquiry
thank you Mr Speaker Mr Speaker if I
know that no taxpayer in our state
should be paying a higher or lower rate
than another taxpayer in our state for a
tax that is supposed to be
constitutionally fair and proportional
and equalized valuation and if I know Mr
Speaker that what my friend who spoke on
the other side of this vote said was
wrong and that this is not a property
tax raise by a quadruple but in fact
property tax relief for many of our
towns that are completely burdened by
having to Shack the burden for the
others and Mr Speaker if I know that
this would follow the Constitution and
our people want us to get this done then
would I then vote red on the itl so that
we could overturn the committee report
and get property tax relief for our
constituents thank you Mr Speaker
speaker representative 's recognized for
parliamentary
inquiry hey I get to
speak Mr Speaker if I know you cannot
reduce taxes by increasing
taxes and if I know this bill increases
property taxes and if I know this bill
takes away resources from essential
government operations such as police
courts prisons highways Etc would I not
then push the green button to support
the itl motion of the
committee the questions on the majority
committee report of inexpedient to
legislate on House Bill 669 this is a
division vote if you're in favor press
the green button opposed press the red
voting stations are open for 30 seconds
[Music]
represent woodcock
have all members present had an
opportunity to vote house will attend to
the state of the vote 2011 in the
affirmative 157 and negative the
committee reports
adopted the house will attend the bill
is removed from the consent calendar the
committee on Municipal and County
government to which is referred House
Bill 123 an act enabling municipalities
to tax standing wood and Timber on land
used for carbon sequestration having
considered the same report the same with
the following Amendment and the
recommendation that the bill ought to
passed with
Amendment representative Diane power for
the
committee for what reason does a member
rise move to lay hb123 on the table
representative Osborne moves to lay a
house bill 123 on the table you ready
for the
question I'm imagine that this will be a
division
vote members take your
seats e
the question is on the motion to table
House Bill
123 representative Osborne's recognized
for parliamentary
inquiry thank you Mr Speaker if I know
that Dr is currently working on a report
on this particular issue that will be
out later this year and I don't want
want to see uh this bill um go down
today on such an important issue that we
do need to address uh would I now press
the green button to lay it on the table
for
now representative ulet recognized for
parliamentary
inquiry thank you Mr
Speaker Mr Speaker if I know that the
committee unanimously voted to recommend
hb123 ought to
pass and if I know this bill is a result
of more than three years of
collaboration by numerous uh subject
matter experts and share
stakeholders and if I further know that
this is not a new tax it is an
application of the normal yield tax on
Timber that has been in statute for 76
years and constitutionally permitted by
part two Article 5 of the state
constitution ratified in 19 42 would I
now vote no to oppose the motion to
table and push a red button thank
you the motion is to lay House Bill 1 23
on the table this is a division vote if
you're in favor press the green button
opposed press the red voting stations
are open for 30 seconds
[Music]
representative missoury
have all members present and an
opportunity to vote the house will
attend to the state of the
vote 171 in the affirmative 185 in the
negative the motion
fails
am all right the amendment is
0654 H printed in house record 15 on
pages 37 to 38 questions on adoption of
the amendment you ready for the question
all those in favor say I I any oppos nay
the eyes have it any amendments
adopted okay motion now is ought to pass
as
amended representative Harrington's
recogniz speak against the committee
report thank you Mr Speaker you know
there's been a lot of talk about what
this bill actually is so let's read what
it is it says it's a tax it says the
total tonnage of carbon credit offsets
issued in the previous year shall be the
amount by the carbon registry and
they're going to charge a fee on that a
yield tax of 10% of the estimated net
value of the carbon offset so someone
enters into a pre a legal contract with
another organization to sell a service
that service is buying and selling
carbon tax credits totally legal nothing
illegal about it at all and now we're
going to turn around and say well if you
do that that income that you get from
that is going to be a tax I call that an
income tax it's a new tax and it's an
income tax there's no other way you can
get around it it also gets assessed
every year on these carbon credits that
are sold and then eventually if the land
owner gets around to selling the wood
they're going to be taxed selling the
wood so they're going to be double taxed
on it and there's no need for a new tax
it's as simple as that and to try to
call it anything else it's just a
disguise a tax is a tax is a tax and
this is an income tax does a member
yield for a
question yes representative verville you
may
inquire thank you uh Mr speaker thank
you represent for taking my my question
would you agree with me that this seems
remarkably similar to an unrealized
capital gains type
tax yes I
would representative chot recognized
speak against the committee
report thank you Mr Speaker good
afternoon everybody I rise in opposition
to hb123 as amended I want to be clear
one thing I am not advocating for or
against carbon credit sequestration I'm
only here to talk about this being
indeed a new tax let's start with the
title of the bill enabling
municipalities to tax standing wood and
Timber on land used for carbon
sequestration the words
enabling that definitely implies it's
something new and to tax that's pretty
obvious are there any existing taxes on
the selling of carbon uh credits no
there are not
and then in the uh in the uh Bill itself
they add a few new de definitions carbon
credits carbon developer and carbon
sequestration now they need those in
there because then they go
in and talk
about definitions required so we can add
several hundred new words into our rsas
for the purpose of describing how to
gain revenue off income
income these companies receive through
the selling of carbon credits this is
not a form of yield
tax as a lot of the proponents attempt
to uh to infer this is a tax on
Revenue so should this bill
pass how many taxes would some land
owners be subjected to now it's been
suggested that many of these carbon
credits taxes would create double
taxation I think I can make the case at
in fact or some solid arguments in fact
that this could actually result in some
cases of triple or even quadruple
Taxation and here's why first we already
have the long established yield tax that
companies and individuals pay when the
Timbers is
harvested second carbon credit companies
are already subjected to business
profits taxes on the revenue they
receive for selling the carbon
credits business profit tax is an income
and they also pay business Enterprise
taxes if you want to count that as one
or two we could actually get to qu
quintuple taxation next we have the
taxing of Revenue based on the selling
of carbon credits being the third bite
at the taxation apple and fourth
although I realize a lot of the lands
are already in uh current use but we
have the property taxes on the land
themselves now I can assure you shortly
if this were to pass shortly after the
passage you're going to see a flurry of
lawsuits being filed on just on this so
who opposes this well we have the
Americans for tax reform known for their
new no new tax
pledge you've got the New Hampshire
Timberland Owners Association you've got
Americans for Prosperity you've got the
New Hampshire business and industry
Association you've got the Thomas family
Tree Farm owners of 25 2400 acres of
land
all oppose this legislation and each of
them opposes it because they have
determined it is indeed a new tax now
there are some other arguments that
aren't related to taxes I'll just throw
out a couple of them quickly um one of
them is that the carbon contracts just
allow Recreation not true the contracts
continue would allow uh continue to
allow Recreation for OHV and
snowmobiles uh another one carbon
contracts prohibit logging no they do
not land owners continue to manage their
manage the land and the timber is
harvested but again none of those that I
just said really have to do with the
reason I'm debating the legislation and
this is about the multiple layers of
Taxation um on a single individual
property so I'm going to ask you to join
me in opposing hb123 as amended so
another U motion can be made thank you
Mr Speaker does a member yield for a
question I do not
representative Davis has recognized
speaking support of the committee
report thank you Mr
Speaker Mr Speaker House Bill 123
addresses the negative impacts that
Cobin sequestration has on New
Hampshire's Timber industry and the
heavily timbered municipality ities this
bill will uh this bill will modify the
existing 60 76 year old tax on Timber to
include the yield of metric tonnage of
carbon sequestration from standing
Timber it is important to New
Hampshire's municipalities that revenues
from this Timber tax be preserved and
all yields from Timber whether from
cutting or sequestration
be accounted
for equally when
assessed House Bill 123 is not a new tax
or a carbon tax B despite what some out
of state interests are pushing this
yield tax on Timber has existed since
1949 House Bill 123
ensures that all Timber yields are
treated the same this is consistent with
the tent of the original Law and ensures
no yield on Timber is
unfairly
excluded this bill is constitutionally
permitted by an amendment to part two
Article 5 of the State Constitution
which was ratified in 1942 by over
two-thirds of New Hampshire's
voters this bill has the support the
strong support of the governor and the
governor's councel who both realize the
importance
and impact this bill has on future the
future of this state this bill came out
of committee 18 to Zer with an ought to
pass as amended recommendation and put
on the consent
calendar cabin credits
in California cap and trade program and
others are where the carbon credits are
being sold tying up our forest for
multiple decades in some instances 100
years the carbon Market is growing and
will continue to impact our Timber
industry in New Hampshire which happens
to be our third largest form of Revenue
a loss of Timber tax will create a tax
burden shift that will increase local
property taxes if we
continue with a cabin first initiative
not only will local property taxes
increase due to loss Timber tax revenues
but forestry and Wood Products
Industries will continue to to decline
as wood will no longer be available
here our forest will become
mismanaged creating issues for
recreation wildlife habitat and forest
fire mitigation ending up with our
forests being owned and controlled by
out of state special
interests selling the benefits to
California companies allowing them to
continue to
pollute I urge this house to support
this amendment this bill as amended to
ensure all Timber yields are treated the
same keeping consistent with the intent
of the original Law let's tell
California and out of state special
interests that our forests are not for
sale thank you Mr Speaker does a member
yield for a question
member yields representative Aaron you
may inquire thank you so much for taking
my question so as I'm concerned about
our farmers and agriculture in the state
I'm interested to know for these carbon
sequestration contracts if a farmer
decides that they want to take several
Acres of their land and grow certain
cover crops which they can intro and
they have been doing this out west that
they can into a carbon sequestration
contract on those cover crops that
sequester nitrogen carbon whatever um
would this bill then impose some sort of
new tax on them for those
contracts thank you for your question
this bill just deals with Timber so
there would no no implication at all
thank you does a member yield for
another question
representative Bixby you may
inquire thank you Mr Speaker and thank
you for taking my question so um my
question
is uh I know that the our forested lands
in the North country are largely not old
growth they are um they've been
harvested and replanted for many years
and there is a real cycle of forest
management that that is required to keep
them mo uh keep them uh as healthy as
possible and I'm concerned that uh if
it's bound up too much in carbon credits
that will uh cause a problem for
the uh for uh the health healthy
management of the forests I'm wondering
if uh having this essentially a a a
taxfree way of holding your Timber would
discourage proper forage
management thank you for your question
I'm I'm going to try to answer that I'm
not exactly sure but
uh the way the reason for Timber tax it
it's not just it wasn't just it was not
just sorry the reason for Timber
tax before that the te taxing that the
municipal assessors would come to your
Timber lot every year and tax you on
that standing Timber whether you cut it
or not and that's because the standing
timber in New Hampshire is part of your
real estate it has a taxable value so
that that's how the system worked and
how people would get away from that they
to circumvent paying that tax what they
would do is they would clearcut their
forests it was no good for the Watershed
it was no good for wildlife habitat it
was no good for any it was a poor
management system and the woods Product
Industry couldn't wouldn't be stable
because there'd be a lot of wood cut and
then it would be few years would go by
and it'd be a big lull so they came up
with Timber tax and what Timber tax is
just a property tax for the
municipalities they know nothing about
the monetary value of the sale of the
Timber or the sale of the carbon
sequestration
so uh when you when you sequester the
carbon it's measured in metric
tonnage so what what would happen is uh
it we're we're looking for best product
uh best Forest management practices by
not cutting your trees for a hundred
years that's almost the polar opposite
of clear cutting them that you know if
we're looking for best forestry
practices this isn't the
way just the the member was not
recognized for a followup thank you
representative Davis
sorry will you take another question no
thank
you the member does not yield all
right the vote is on the committee
report of ought to pass as amended are
you roll call okay who asked for that
representative tur cart request a roll
call it's sufficiently seconded it's a
roll call vote members take your seats
for
the questions on the majority committee
report have about to pass as amended on
House Bill 123 representative Turk C
recognized for parliamentary inquiry
let's settle
down thank you Mr Speaker if I know this
bill would indeed create a new tax if I
know businesses involved with the
selling of carbon credits already are
subjected to the BET tax the BPT tax
Timber harvesting tax and the underlying
property tax
itself and finally if I know that any
single form of Taxation on a piece of
property is burden enough but multiple
layers of taxes on the same piece of
property truly endorsees the fact that
taxation is theft then would I now press
the red button to overturn the otpa
motion thank you Mr
Speaker representative ulet recognized
for parliamentary
inquiry thank you Mr
Speaker if I know that in 20
2024 21 towns of the 234 in the state of
New Hampshire received Timber Tac Timber
tax income to help reduce property taxes
and if I know this is just a
modernization of RSA 79 and Clos the
loophole Timber companies are using to
evade property taxes and keeping towns
whole and if I know this bill affects
eight properties in the state of New
Hampshire and has nothing to do with
land conservation or current use
and if I know the governor supports this
bill and we'll sign it if we get it to
her now would I press the green button
to send this bill forward thank
you questions on the majority committee
report of ought to pass as amended on
House Bill 123 there's a roll call vote
if you're in favor press the green
button oppos press the red voting
stations are open for 30 seconds
[Music]
have all members present had an
opportunity to vote the house will
attend to the state of the
vote 197 in the affirmative 158 in the
negative the reports adopted and House
Bill 123 is referred to the committee on
Ways and Means
enjoy for what reason does a member rise
I don't know where everybody's going
we're not
done the house will be in
order for what reason does a member rise
to make a motion State your motion I'd
like to um move to take House Bill 764
off the table representative Penza moves
that house bill 764 be removed from the
table are you ready for the
question yes it'll be a division
everybody take your seat
representative Penza requests a roll
call is that sufficiently
seconded it is not sufficiently seconded
this will be a division vote what you
got to get up faster I'm not going to
wait oh my gosh it's a division vote
members take your seats not a discussion
whole point was a roll for doing this
the question is whether
to the question is whether to remove
House Bill 764 from the table
representative pen is recognized for
parliamentary
inquiry Mr Speaker if I know that a
large majority want to try to overturn
the itl on HB 764 so my floor amendment
can be considered and if I also know
that it's late and I promise that the if
the itl is overturned I will keep my
speech to under three minutes and lastly
if I know we owe it to the thousands in
New Hampshire that have reached out to
me in multiple sponsors over the last
three years would I now press the green
button so another motion can be can move
forward and I really wanted a roll call
vote but that's not happening
[Music]
the motion is to remove House Bill 764
from the table if you're in favor press
the green button oppos press the red
voting stations are open for 30 seconds
[Music]
represent har cath right
all members present had an opportunity
to vote the house will attend of the
state of the vote 114 and the
affirmative 231 or negative motion
fails I
one chair recognizes the member from
Auburn representative Osborne for the
third reading motion and before
everybody heads out we have six
unanimous consents
tonight resolve that the house now
adjourned from the early session the
business of the late session be in order
at the present time that the reading of
bills be by title only and resolutions
by caption only and that all bills
ordered a third reading be read a third
time by this resolution and that all
titles of bills be the same as adopted
and that they be passed at the present
time and when the house adjourns today
it be to meet Thursday March 20th at 10
a.m. questions on a third reading motion
all in favor say I any oppos nay eyes
have it and the motion's
adopted if you are leaving please keep
it down so that we can hear the members
who are
speaking representative Damon is
recognized for unanimous consent on
women's History Month
thank you Mr
Speaker okay people I know we all want
to go
home and many of us think this is
important I Rise to offer a celebration
of women that denigrates no one women's
life experiences are different than
men's we need all women's voices at all
the tables in positions to make
collaborative decisions
role models and mentoring are incredibly
important to young people seeing folks
who can relate to serving in leadership
roles helps young people Envision
themselves serving in similar
positions I am the granddaughter of a
suffragette Mabel Merritt 1895 to
2000 yes she touched three centuries and
lived to be
105 Graham was 25 when women got the
right to vote in the US
she understood the privilege of voting
and never missed an election Graham is
my personal woman in history my Shiro
today I've chosen eight New Hampshire
spend for a minute can we swing those
doors shut if you're going through them
open them close them behind you this way
we're not hearing all the noise from the
an
room swing the door
shut thank you Pro
thank you I appreciate
that today I've chosen eight New
Hampshire women to represent the
thousands of strong resilient creative
determined women who are making New
Hampshire history as I briefly
acknowledge these extraordinary women I
ask you to also reflect on the women who
contribute to your opportunities and
successes teacher astronaut and Mom
Christa Corgan McCulla
the beautiful bronze statue on our state
house Plaza inspires me every single day
when I walk
across CEO and president of Dartmouth
Health New Hampshire's largest private
employer Dr Joanne Conroy who marries
Medicine Science and business every day
Kelsey Brook eert award-winning history
teacher founder of the impressive
remedial HST Tre project an amazing new
New Hampshire based nonprofit that works
to get women's history into
curriculum Patrick Wiggins Newport New
Hampshire native third generation mill
worker turned tapestry artist and
independent scholar Patrick literally
weaves the pref Precision Valley history
and culture into her tapestry that has
been exhibited at the Smithsonian folk
Life
Festival Rebecca Hamilton and Emily
scharn white sisters and co-ceos of WS
Badger company a global business created
and based in Gillum New Hampshire with
over 100 natural and organic products
sold
worldwide Jody Lynn peo New Hampshire
best-selling author whose
well-researched novels explore social
issues and themes like family
dysfunction racism betrayal Redemption
and Reproductive Rights Jodi's novels
have initiated many stimulating
multigenerational
discussions these women are chosen
deliberately to rep represent the Arts
science business nonprofit work and
Educators I also acknowledge every woman
in an elected role and all of the
amazing State House staff who work so
hard to help us be
productive I have saved the most
important women in history my reed for
my last
recognition quoting a high school
teacher who inspired many students years
ago there are those who have climbed
Mount Everest and those who have
descended the depths of the maranis
trench and there are footprints on the
moon but what is the challenge and worth
of those singular obsessions compared
with a person who at the sound of the
alarm clock tries to put together a day
a week a month and make a meaningful
life here lies the true challenge so to
me the greatest women making history
today are those who spend each and every
day endeavoring to make a living to
provide for their families to show that
they care The Single Moms the nurses on
every long shift the cashiers the
teachers the farmers the seemingly
ordinary who are in reality
extraordinary for their persistence hard
work and
resilience as one example I honor Sarah
Kathleen who works so hard and with such
kindness as an aid at Sullivan County
Nursing
Home sail around the world alone in a
tiny sailboat and you will be held for
your courage and excite the Press get
two people to agree teach empathy show
compassion get another or yourself to
reexamine a dee rooted conviction and it
may well go unnoticed but that is what
contributes most to humankind and that
is what the most extraordinary women in
history do as we leave here today I
encourage you to recognize the ordinary
yet extraordinary women you see and
appreciate them thank you and may the
Irish luck be with you this
weekend for what reason does a member
RZ yes I'd like you I'd like the
previous remarks to be put into the
permanent joury please without
objection representative ger is
recognized for unanimous consent on
civility in the
house thank you Mr
Speaker as president keny as President
Kennedy said back in
1963 I'm talking about genuine peace the
kind of peace that makes life on Earth
worth living the kind that enables men
women and Nations to grow to Hope and to
build a better life for their children
not merely peace for all Americans but
peace for all
Americans and all men and women not
merely peace in our time but peace in
all
times I ran for the idea of that piece
and being a part of it I ran to be my
part to do my part in this honorable
body and to do what is right for granite
Staters I speak now to both sides of the
aisle in a message of unity we are here
to be the adults and to represent our
constituents while having these diffic
while having these difficult debates on
the direction of our
state we spend a lot of time talking
about voter
disengagement um especially with the
younger
generation being a 21y old myself I get
to have a pretty good Insight onto why
that is in a world with the housing
crisis and a homelessness crisis and a
drug crisis
in a world set up for the rich to get
richer while the middle class pays their
way while paying cripp crippling student
loans and medical debt in a world where
we have attacked on eggs when we go out
to the
restaurant as a as state representatives
we choose to spend our time instead
attacking and silencing each other we
spend our time taking our phones out and
recording while we laugh and point at
our colleagues
when we are sworn in we are given the
title of the honorable but we often fail
to live up to
that well we have an opportunity now to
come together around a tough budget that
our constituents are going to feel the
impacts
of this
starts with staying quiet and really
listening to debates not just looking at
the sheets that we're given but being
involved into what our constituents are
going to be feeling the impact of
this starts with reading online
testimony about these bills about the
effects that these are going to have on
real graned Staters or constituents that
sent us here to fix the problems for
them this starts with erasing the D the
r and the I from next to our names as
the problem that we have in this country
is with dri and not
Dei it is time to make the government
work for the people and not against each
other thank
[Applause]
you for what reason doesn't remember us
I was told I shouldn't but I'm going to
and I hope no one will blame me blame me
I moov that the members remarks be
placed in the permanent journal without
objection it's so ordered representative
Simpsons recognized re Anonymous consent
on jeene
Shaheen thank you Mr Speaker good
evening
colleagues yesterday our state senior
Senator jeene Shaheen announced that
she'll not seek
reelection a Trailblazer Senator Shaheen
made history as the first woman in US
history elected both governor and US
senator
she has spent decades championing New
Hampshire advocating for common sense
leadership and bipartisan
cooperation since taking office in 2009
she's fought for granite Staters on key
issues expanding Health Care access
securing funding to combat the opioid
crisis and supporting small businesses
her work on the Senate armed services
and Foreign Relations committees has
strengthened National Security and she's
been a fierce advocate for veterans
women's rights and climate
action Senator Shaheen played a key role
in passing the Affordable Care Act
ensuring thousands in New Hampshire
could access care she's also worked to
lower prescription drug costs and
protect Reproductive Rights her
leadership on Energy Efficiency has
saved families and businesses
billions before serving in Washington go
Senator Shaheen was a three-term
governor creating thousands of jobs
expanding public kindergarten and
keeping New Hampshire's tax burden among
the lowest in the country even in
moments of political disagreement
there's no doubt that Senator Shaheen
has always fought hard for what she
believes is best for our state her
Decades of service have left an
indelible mark on New Hampshire and our
nation we know she'll be working hard
for granite sters for the next two years
until the moment she leaves office but
today we want to take a moment to extend
our deepest gratitude for for her
leadership and her commitment to New
Hampshire thank
you what reason does a member rise I
move that the remarks from the member
from exitor be placed in the permanent
journal without objection so
ordered representative veral recognized
for ious consent on the anniversary of
the 4:30
session thank you Mr Speaker um
hopefully it's not like deja vu all over
again I wrote a a pretty long uh pretty
long speech uh but I'll try to I'll try
to make it quick thank you for for
staying um as many of you will remember
five years ago
today this body held one of its longest
session days if not it's longest session
day in its August
history in
fact 5 years ago yesterday the house was
scheduled for two full days of
session staring down a daunting
182 bills on the regular
calendar on
Wednesday we disposed of a meager 37
bills leaving the
remaining 145 bills for the next day
Thursday March 12th
2020 this is not the only thing that
made that day
historic as the panic over the covid-19
was washing over the great state our
great nation and the world unprecedented
motions and actions became part of our
order of business that day we began that
day at 9:00
a.m. after disposing of some 55
bills at
7:35
p.m. there was a motion to amend house
rule
65 by adding a new subparagraph B that
read in an effort to thwart the spread
of
covid-19 after concurrence from the
Democratic and Republican leadership
and public health officials about best
practices concerning the safety of
Representatives staff and the
public the deadlines may be reasonably
amended at the discretion of the speaker
of the house to be timely noticed in the
house calendar and on the general court
website that motion was adopted by the
necessary 2third vote
that sub paragraph is no longer part of
House Rules by the wisdom of subsequent
legislator after disposing of some 84
bills at approximately 10:40
p.m. a motion was made that the house
rules be so far
suspended as to allow the remaining
bills on the calendar to be taken up at
a date to be determined determined by
the
speaker the house took a 5minute
recess and a heated debate on the motion
ensued after only two
speakers both against the pending
motion a motion to limit debate passed
on a roll call
vote it was noted during that debate by
Yours Truly that just a few weeks
earlier on Wednesday February 19th 2020
to be
exact the house wasted the better half
the better part of a half of a session
day reprimanding members for refusing to
participate in allegedly compulsory
professional
development I was one of the house
members that was reprimanded reprimanded
on that inauspicious
day the motion to suspend house rules
failed to attain the required 2third
affirmative vote and the motion failed
session continued into the evening the
aformentioned debate is printed in the
permanent
Journal after disposing of some 95 bills
at approximately 12:22 a.m. on Friday
the 13th of March
2020 a member motioned
that the house
adjourn this was an all but
unprecedented move it would have left
some 87 bills
abandoned and would have ended the
legislative
session but there's a bright side the
motion failed 41 to
247 uh yeah 247 on a roll call vote
session continued into the we hours of
the
morning many of us were the house having
disposed of 182 bills on the regular
calendar recessed at approximately 400
a.m. on Friday the 13th March
2020 What
followed was the
inFAMOUS two weeks to flatten the curve
Global lockdown down and other assorted
and Sury Madness in response to the
perceived threat of the dangers of
covid-19 May our Republic never react to
an emergency in such a manner again but
by the grace of God thank you Mr Speaker
[Applause]
[Music]
for what reason doesn't member rise a
motion that the remarks be put in the
permanent journal without objection so
ordered representative harrian is
recognized for unanimous
cons
Oregon there was a squiggle on it Oregon
Cold War and the Ukraine
all right anyway I was a very very small
part of the end of the Cold War I was a
civilian employee at the US Army cold
resent research and Engineering lab in
Hanover that's at 45 Li Road in Havener
2.6 miles north of the Dartmouth campus
so if they ever have an open house you
should visit It Anyway beginning in 1991
and continuing through the first half of
the 1990s I was a GS5 physical science
technician which is very low pay grade
the federal government has many many pay
grades above that it was an odd place
for a PN pnic like me it was a great
experience I don't think I was the only
peace Nick working there um the official
end of the Cold War is marked as uh
boxing day December the day after
Christmas December 26 1991 but sort of
the end of the Cold War the beginning of
the cold peace was a process that took
several years and the story of krell's
role in creating that peace is a long St
the cold piece is a long story which has
never been told but don't worry I'm not
going to tell it tell it now lot of the
details were above my pay grade
anyway um let's just say that some very
smart people uh from New Hampshire and
of course a lot from Vermont because
Vermont was right across the river in
Alaska because we had a facility
facilities in Alaska but especially here
in New Hampshire well we worked very
hard to bring peace to the former Soviet
Union in particular the former Soviet
republics of Kazakhstan bellarus and
especially Ukraine you've probably heard
of Ukraine had literally hundreds of
nuclear installations on their
property um Krell was one of the lead
agencies in the effort to clean up the
nuclear and non-nuclear waste left
behind by the Russian military Ukraine
in
particular which is actually a fairly
large country we T it's smaller than
Russia smaller than USA but it's a large
it's a um
large country it could have become the
world's third largest nuclear power but
they chose not
to um they still have a very strong
conventional military actually strong
enough to fight Russia to a stalemate
multiple times and they've also unlike
Russia managed to be a democracy with um
the current phase with the current phase
of the Russia Ukrainian War has gone on
for almost three years now actually
entire War has gone on for 11 years now
anyway it is now time to make peace but
it must I I hope it should be a real
peace on terms which allowed Ukraine to
continue to be Democratic and strong not
a piece where we in the USA Force the
Americans to capitulate to Putin so uh
thank you very much Mr Speaker and Slava
ukraini thank you
[Applause]
representative Howard has recognized for
unanimous consent on speech on
campuses thank you Mr Speaker and
honorable
Representatives last year our great
state of New Hampshire signed into law
HB 1305 reaffirming the state's
commitment to freedom of speech on
college campuses in line with the
principles of the first
Amendment as the general court is aware
we saw arrests of both pro-israeli and
pro Palestinian students uh during a
protest on May 1st 2024 over the summer
a working group was formed to
investigate the incident in January the
group published a final report detailing
their
findings regardless of how you feel in
the Middle
East about the situation in the Middle
East it is almost and was in certainly
an unacceptable abuse of power by the
state and a flagrant violation of the
principles of the First
Amendment which we the state have
committed ourselves to uphold in HB
1305 UNH president Elizabeth Chilton who
convened that said working group has
chosen to ignore their findings whether
or not the University Administration
agrees with the working group uh in
their findings choosing simply to ignore
the findings that do not match the
conclusion most favorable to the
university is undemocratic anti-liberal
and ultimately authoritarian abuse of
power by an unelected bureaucrat for
those not aware the primary
recommendation of the working group uh
was an independent investig which was an
independent investigation by an outside
Law Firm into the events of May first as
the actions of both the university
administrators and the police violated
students Constitution right I bring this
issue before you the body today because
we are seeing political attacks on
students for expressing their views
permanent residents fear having their
green cards revoked and endure threats
of expulsion for using their first
amendment rights this is wrong
unconstitutional it needs to be pointed
out thank you
[Music]
for what reason does the member rise I
move to put the remarks of the previous
speaker in the permanent journal without
objection so
ordered representative Osborne moves at
the house stand in recess for the
purpose of the introduction of bills
vacate motions and roll Bill amendments
and roll Bill reports and receiving
messages are you ready for the question
all those in favor say I I any opposed
nay the eyes have it and the Motions
adopted the house is in recess till
Thursday March 20th
2025 at 10 a.m.